did you show him your white spot yeah
that's your songs yeah i'm hard right
now dude i'm gonna make sure everyone
says let me zoom in on the possibilities
look at that
dude
oh yeah
that's good
[Laughter]
hey what's up guys
my name is hans kim this is
michael this is chris this is mumford
this is nick this is ant
and we're all here talking about the
hottest awesome comic
scene right now
who do you think it is
oh man the scene in the scene no i don't
name this okay anyways
do you think uh blind glasses today that
was pretty about um
dalen mendoza
loki if he had a wig i'd [ __ ] him
he did have a wig
yeah that one night he dressed like a
hooker yeah he looked pretty good that
night
it's good to know
so
yeah talking about something
yeah i don't know oh i thought we just
got strange in the guitar well what do
you think about the awesome comedy scene
it's amazing it's pretty dope it's cool
i like it it's alcohol and pizza
everywhere and then there's mike's in a
party time homeless people and homeless
people shits
there's tons of that homeless people
piss yeah there's a lot of that a lot of
albums outside of arch
we were walking by arch and i saw a guy
with a blanket and he was just getting
jiggy under the blanket that's good oh
yes dude
yeah he's just happening
straight
me meeting in pub
wasn't
but it was under the blanket he was
under the blanket which is fair but i
definitely pointed at it
i do like the idea that he's like you
just no cause he was in the beat off
tent you know you know what i'm saying
like when you're at like [ __ ] uh
summer camp or something
you put the blanket over you're like
it's like it's like the concept of a
harry potter invisibility club but
everyone can obviously see you're
beating off under a blanket like it's
like you can't see me you're like nah
dude you're definitely beating your dick
under there
yeah it was nice
oh yeah this is the big city that is
funny because he's got i mean
this is good
talking about homestead's beating office
if you start yeah fun
so anyone know how to put things on the
green screen
i would love to
put
it's a good curtain how do you change
that
i don't know
can we put space up there
yeah just put in a japanese tidal wave
painting
yeah kick the whites off
don't kick me off
yeah well just the whites in their place
we'll just tape we'll just tape
momford's eyes back yeah
davis becomes the first trans-racial
asian comedian
but he still has that beard
they wouldn't accept me if i was trans
black trans asian
immediately maybe
[Laughter]
all
right no more races we're just like
y'all just don't understand us so you
don't know
six
i love nintendo did you get the link
did you send it back on instagram okay
eight
what'd you get six uh i got nine
six eight i get an eight i have a ten oh
oh it's my turn
you got the dice
i met seven
what do you think about how kill tummy
and the best squad show
four the joe rogan shows have influenced
austin comedy to become greater than
just
you know there's like a sea there's a
higher ceiling there's like you know
it's like there's something to shoot for
there's a ladder
to the top and it gives people hope and
it makes some practices having them
perform for a real audience
yeah
it's good for people like me who've just
been in like the hyperbolic time chamber
of open mic comedy
you've just been grinding for years and
years and learning how to do comedy and
you didn't really have any like you get
booked here and there but nothing really
leads to the next thing right
mates yeah i'm very stagnated back home
i don't really have any structure i'm
like well i'll just keep grinding and
getting funny and keep writing jokes and
then maybe one day something will fall
into my lap you're just blindly hoping
that something is out there but here
there's like you can like [ __ ] see it
yeah literally within three days i had
in three days of being here that
happened yeah it all worked out got
really lucky
it was pretty chill that was crazy
it's cause like uh you know you have to
get picked and then it had to all happen
like that but it all feels really fair i
never felt like you know what i mean
yeah feels like it is fair yeah yeah so
who got the highest number you got ten
ten
yeah one
i got four
did you get the link yeah i already
showed you
you put it on your story yes sir
oh you got the what do you mean like
copy it like click on it and then like
if you're friends i don't know how to do
that hans i'm sorry yes to copy and
paste
that's how i graduated from college
copy and pasting yeah dude plagiarism
the only way to get plagiarism you can't
do in college
not if you're a [ __ ] yeah
i cheated my way all through college
yeah that's how you get a mechanical
engineering degree that's why this is
how you get a religion degree dude just
copy and paste oh [ __ ] mechanically
do i put the houses down there yeah
all right one house in one road
[Music]
bro that's one of the best
disney movies damn i got five i'm so bad
no
you don't have a road one house
so what do you think about like
the whole
journey of kill tony like is it like fun
and do you guys
enjoy
you know
the whole
the uh the backstory behind it all and
backstory
i don't know any culture i don't know
anything about i i know i've watched a
lot of the old episodes it's in my car
yeah
no i think it's like
no it's
it goes to the left
i think it's cool i mean it's a cool
platform for a lot of people that like
you know
yeah
people that do well on it for sure i
mean
it's
it's definitely uh
i don't know it's a fun thing to see for
sure
with everything going on with cancel
culture the last six years kill tony's
like a weird little
bubble liminal space where it's like
kind of like restoring comedy in a way
to where like anybody who watches it
doesn't give a [ __ ] about anything they
just want to laugh yeah so it's a good
it filters out the [ __ ] yeah yeah
it's good for austin
kind of creates like a funnel though
of like what gets through of like the
[ __ ] that people have to worry about
it is good practicing in front doing big
shows like that for some people yeah
no it's just one it gets you ready oh
you only do one right
yeah
you like to figure out what that
audience really is instead of just
imagining what that audience is right
now this is what it actually is and
you can write with that audience in mind
well for a lot of people starting out
it's tough to really like get up in
front of that many people yeah like what
other chance are you going to have
on a monday night to go up in front of
that many people
i'm looking forward to tomorrow for sure
yeah hopefully we
y'all somebody out of towners actually
have good luck man it pisses me off man
there's one week where there are like
six people from boston who got up and i
was like what the [ __ ] yeah
that's like the general consensus you
kind of learned that like
yeah people like whoa you guys all came
out of town and you guys all got on
that's crazy it took me a few months of
being here yeah but then i got on twice
in a row two weeks
[Music]
both days she got on
two days in a row and got on first both
days that she got on yeah so she was the
bullet first
like both both times she got let's pull
a name out of this bucket and it was
[ __ ] rachel
is she uh
traveling she's just visiting i think so
yeah she's like yeah she's funny
she's like new she's like a year in okay
and she did pretty good for being a year
in tune all right time
i thought i was jennifer's boyfriend
what yeah tony you called genevieve's oh
yeah
you already got a white comic that works
here
yeah yeah
it was funny when he said that uh
the only people laughing at that are
alcoholics
they just wanted no one stands for most
comedians
i love orange at this point
i was orange yesterday
and you were green yesterday you were
green yesterday i was green i'm changing
i'm
doing better yeah
it was white yesterday i was white
yesterday oh okay
his name is
look at him
in your face whitey
oh
oh we can't see i get it i get strong
strong napoleon dynamite vibes from you
oh dude
i'm not pulling in dynamite yeah it's
because
that's what this girl used to call me in
school you talking you sound just like
but she was also i was like the yearbook
committee thing so i had to pay her for
my yearbook and i paid her in change
what was your superlative
uh i didn't get one
most likely
i was most likely to not get a
superlative most likely
describe most likely to shoot up the
swiss describable yeah
yeah they thought i was going to but i
didn't
do you know what i'm saying jokes on
them
wow what a wonderful audience
i like
did we watch that episode the other day
or no have we not watched that one yet i
don't think we watched that yeah it's a
good episode you guys have been on
america just like us yeah we've just
been going through like cherry picking
all the good episodes yeah which is
pretty challenging
man all right so staple of our household
yeah
everybody put their uh all right all
right who goes for
them
asian trash
is your turn again put down my turn
again yeah i put down another one yeah
well my parents wouldn't even let me
watch the simpsons really my dad got me
i started watching south park at eight
with my dad like my dad was here check
this out we were living it's just
another road right yeah
anywhere on the board another road and
settlement yeah
but you can do it anywhere on the board
that's such an asian trash thing
instead of white trash you say yeah yeah
yellow trash all right cool
i went
so then now it's back yeah to me you
know that you didn't have to connect it
right
i know that
okay
hans is like these [ __ ] stupid white
people
those are good spots
i picked a better spot today
boxing copyright music is over here
yeah you should pick up your second
settlement the rock the sheep and the
wood
the rock the sheep and the wood not you
uh nick i should pick up the rock the
sheep and the wood you should pick up
your second settlement the rock the
sheep and the wood
the rock
the sheep
and
the wood
all right baron give it up let's take
the terrible places that's good
yeah i'll do it
yeah
yeah [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ]
do you know what i'm saying yes i know
what you were saying
yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you should be i
could get some real [ __ ] money
call me steve
oh boy
so what did you think of the creek
tonight what a riot
oh yeah
right that was awesome the four people
that were sitting there when i was still
telling my jokes yeah uh yeah i heard
there was one comic that went up that
totally sucked the energy out of it yeah
he he murdered in the worst possible it
was very bad
after we left multiple times on stage
i heard
i don't even know why i'm doing this
it wasn't none of us knew that sounded
right big fancy okay who started the
chant
who started someone started saying he
started a ridley channel
urban crew in the corner hell yeah oh
yeah
they're i'm well received i'm well
received by the urban crew you just got
lucky
[Laughter]
i am very lucky
i'm a lucky guy
i'm a wild boy maybe you came on stage
in a great way
when i thought for the canadians i think
those guys did a good job of raising the
roof yeah canadians hey
yeah i didn't have any problems coming
up after them they were very funny
is it my turn to put another house in a
road down yeah
museums are so funny i think it's
because they have health care so they
can just focus on that
you don't have to worry about like
getting uh dropping four grand for a cat
scan to see if they have like a
potential aneurysm around the corner
yeah happier
man you guys look at jason rouse and
he's like
always justin black talking about jason
marazz
yeah yeah i thought you said america's
got uh
pick up your second settlements
second settlements yeah you already did
it
okay can i put one you get one of each
card
i mean like in sweden like metal was
really popular
because like when you're that happy you
like gotta manufacture your
your
struggles i think this is called being
white
so what whichever settlement you pick
second
i need a second one yeah go ahead
so which one did you put you put that
yes one second no no
so pick up the three resources around
that
and you put
this
and this
you pick up those two
and which one did you put down a second
brick and stone
i'll take them you're breaking my stones
brick and stone excuse me chris yeah
what happened yeah okay which settlement
did you put down second
that one okay pick up two sheep and a
wood you're breaking my stones two sheep
in a wood
what do i even pick up right here
um
you put that down a second yes yeah she
brought wheat
yeah six
did you see that couple get kicked out
no
yeah right up front oh yeah what the 22
year old guy is that dude he's trying to
sell drugs to that chick
is that what it was in the restaurant he
kept saying like you guys want coke you
guys need molly you know there's a weird
guy yeah
that girl like on her way out walked
into three tables just
oh no wonder he was talking to her man
he's trying to get laid did we just
watch someone
we stopped to cry
on someone well i went outside to watch
the rap concert and they were definitely
uh getting jiggy
i was staring a little too long dude i
was getting a little torrent they were
they were [ __ ] dude their tongues
like they're you could they were making
out like did they just meet each other
they were making out like gen xers in a
sports bar like [ __ ] just tongues
wrapping around right yeah like
there was like i was getting they were
like on the next level of making us
that's exactly what they did it was like
gen x [ __ ] before gen x like leaves
to go home and [ __ ] that's like it's
pretty like how japanese people kiss
[Music]
sometimes
that's all right
copyrighted
oh you're allowed to do that about
tongues
did they know each other from before i
have no idea not at all
they came together
i don't know bro but she was like
on these people she was like four foot
nine and like a hundred pounds she was
like she was in high school that's very
small it's hot dude
[Music]
chris likes the spinners i do oh you
like to ride spinners hey
yeah what is a spinner i like a real
dinner fidget spinner fidget spinners
spinner is like a girl that's so small
that you like put on your wiener and
like spin it around
yeah
the kind of girl that you could pick up
by the abdomen and kind of [ __ ] like a
fleshlight
i've never tried baby
a baby
yeah i've never had a spinner
yeah but yeah have you ever had a sister
you've been lost for dinner
[Music]
every girl you [ __ ] should be a spinner
like a six foot girl would be a spinner
to you she was like 130 and like six
foot that's a spinner to you a spinner
to me would be like
five foot one and like a hundred pounds
are you done chris
uh
i didn't even roll well i think uh
spinner
it's all about the friction of the ass
cheeks on your pelvis oh yeah yeah so
you gotta lube up that nine baby
nine again
just date girls who uh
day girls who break dance
oh
i don't like wearing those oh yeah those
girls end up being like the blackest
asian girls
which ones whose [ __ ]
the ones that can break dance
yeah i get that aquafina [ __ ] yeah
i do actually enjoy her black cinnamon
that is kind of hot she's kind of cool
well that's just like every filipino
girl that my sister hung out with
so my sister had a couple of aquafina
friends like feliz somers did you have a
crush on one all of them hell yeah dude
it's nice when they have confidence and
they can express themselves
but it's annoying when they have to
always be on and they're always playing
this weird ass
character like just be real with me
oh hail though
eight
damn
like a rock
aquafina did this thing where she
announced she replaced the announcer in
the subway in new york for like a month
sorry uh anyone have a brick
but it is so annoying everyone hated it
because she did a little joke like oh
that reminds me of the time and flushing
when i was like shut the [ __ ] i'm trying
to get to work
trying to get to work no no it's two
sheep for one brick
[Music]
i have no break
no
now i'll do that
you will okay
yeah i'll do that thanks man i'll get
another brick
five
do you know what i'm saying
i don't know why i keep getting [ __ ]
congested out here that's [ __ ] what
are you gonna have the pawns or
yeah this place is horrible
virginia people get bad pollen uh tree
pollen i gotta i gotta comment but you
don't have to be small to be a spinner
dummies oh yeah
you just have to have good score
strength yeah commentaries
is it about core strength
i don't have core strength you got to
have have a good uh intro into it yeah
you got to just lie there as the dude
you have to like a figure skater if you
play your arms then you spin
[Laughter]
will you trade break for
wood
you'll give me some wood yeah i'll give
you wood
copper that is
i don't think so
will anyone is anyone willing to trade
wood for brick
you can see my car i cannot see your car
i'll look at them i can tell there's
gonna be a long game because nobody has
brick that's how it was last night god
damn it's always like this
[Music]
what did you wrote window whoever
whoever's blue should have the most
brick yeah everybody
hey
anthony cavallo gave you a dollar
ninety-nine to the best comedian hans
kim
what i'll try to do i got you anthony i
saw it bro okay i'll
yeah i don't need that all right man
[ __ ] yourself oh dude tony's in here no
never mind different tony uh
yeah mom for your turn
this guy i like this because it kind of
looks like a top hat
best friend for dave yes nine
[Music]
does anyone have any brick
do you want to trade some sheeps
some sheep
no i don't need anything so i'm gonna
trade four sheeps for one brick
technically we're having less sex than
any other generation before
t is very low these days too
i mean i think it's marginally low i
don't think it's
i don't i think it's a third party
effect there was a nine you guys so
we're having less sex now more than ever
before
whose fault do you think it is men or
women
why are we having less sex is it our
fault because men are too horny all the
time or is it because women because
women want to focus on their careers
unrealistic expectations
and because they're narcissists and they
don't think anyone measures up to them
even though they're actually like a sex
this is what you need to do okay you
just need to find the hottest girl with
the lowest self-esteem uh-huh you need
to find a hot girl any girl on west 6th
street
i like i like west so you gotta go past
congress
[Laughter]
congress will sap a woman of everything
she's [ __ ] dude
i don't i don't know the
reference well i think like men are less
sexy when they have less money and we
have less money like we don't have any
control we got to try harder and economy
that's true
eight
eight
game is [ __ ] [ __ ] i just keep
rolling eight
10 10 10 baby 10 10 baby
you know what i'm saying
but i don't like blame the whole gender
i just think like
and before nice guys finish last
sometimes you got to [ __ ] people
sometimes she's got what you're not
saying and just just be confident i
don't know
you got to be in the real world you
can't just be in your fantasy world all
the time
wow
look at han's dropping wisdom yeah on
skin tells you to unplug from the matrix
so do so
yeah there's something you don't
like to do every now and then
michael you want some hay for uh for a
stone
how many
one one for one one for one yeah i'll
cut that down one v1
hey hit me up if you need them rocks i'm
slinging them all night yeah yeah i got
rockstars all right i know you are i got
rocks for days cub
anyone got a brick
what do you need and i got rock i got
sheep
my sheep
oh i won
i can't tell you
how many i have yeah all right one for
one you can't trade right now oh you
gotta wait till it's your turn can we
just trade this one time no you cannot
trade right now
over
what are you doing
i was trying to watch to see the thing
what
[Laughter]
that was so funny you became
his hand lost aim
you're just trying to grab his dick
are you seeing that jiff where the the
nba player is rubbing the guy's knee and
he thinks it's his oh
we just watched that happen in real time
okay
sometimes when we touch
just keep rolling that one
i've been living off those
vulcan event the vaping the vape vending
machine
there's a lot of bees sorry yeah the
vapor
machine
is vengeance
you know
you know the those
vending machine at vulcan
it's just the girls upstairs that's
called my ex-girlfriend
but i mean it's just like hard i feel
like whenever i go up to talk to a girl
they're like
they're not really
down for it what aren't you like a
superstar on monday nights
yeah but it's a long week
there's six other days where he's just a
normal guy
but monday is my day i'm king on monday
yeah dude that should be a thing and
that's 60 seconds
60 seconds
and preceding seven to ten minutes
afterwards
hans did girls come up to you after the
month after shang chi came out
no no did you get any [ __ ]
i had like six months coming for me the
month after they come in
they're like can i show you my ten rings
they're all inside my vagina
he puts it in pulls it out his dick
looks like the girl the girls in the
country where they stretch the neck out
with the rings yeah she has a nine inch
dick now
but it's really thin
oh
[Music]
would anybody like to trade me some
wood for some sheep no no you need sheep
yeah no
how much wood do you need i need a lot
look i'll give you three if you trade me
a brick in with what you've got
we're making deals tonight guys we're
making some deals wait because you've
been hitting on some bricks so you'll
give me three wood yeah
for one brick
yeah give him that brick dude okay oh
[ __ ] that wood give him that brick
thanks for the wood you're welcome that
here you go all right what color are you
with me
all right
11. the wandering m asks hans from
chomply i grew up there way before it
became a korean community
just naming korean communities
wait what'd you roll i rolled an 11 why
is it oh
anthony was your role i don't know
he rolled
when i stroke my little
[Music]
just became a japanese uri
will anyone trade
before
don't understand it
thank you
surprise you don't have any sapporo
is [ __ ] right now
thank god for us asians stimulating the
economy i'm gonna use my religion degree
and monopolize
win oh dude
how do you see the people commenting on
the streaming [ __ ]
you can you could do it go to the link
i did
what did you want i'll just take this oh
one for one with that i'll get it i
think you got to build
you got to build a road before you build
a house right you gotta have two roads
between oh [ __ ] whatever
yeah
yeah we're clearing out that fridge
tonight all right
that's the way i think
no i thought it'd last longer
you guys uh would
what's a great conversation we could be
having right now
i'm trying to play the game
hans who's your favorite uh like comic
working right now
[Laughter]
did you get to work with shane
yeah i got to work with shane did you
get to chit chat with him did you give
him a hug yeah
yeah he's a normal dude it's just like
you and i
oh he's not like me because he's
considerably taller
oh yeah he's bigger than most of us
he's a very nice guy he's very sweet you
know
always joshing
definitely joshie yeah
for sure definitely josh
yeah shane is so smart
i like his skits yeah dude
he could recover from being i'm done
would you run that scale i rolled a
seven oh okay cool did you move the rock
oh my god they heard the [ __ ] i said you
know
all my favorite comedians end up getting
cancelled for like
[Laughter]
do you know what i'm saying
i like the stuff he did in the 90s oh no
not that one oh all the sexual offenses
not my rock i'm just kidding
all right momford do you want to do that
trade from earlier now that's my turn
what do you need
i already traded
man [ __ ] y'all man let me know on
chancellor kim
who do you like who's your favorite
working comic
shane's definitely high up for sure my
jungle brain isn't designed for this
game
those dudes are really good but i think
out of the three of them i feel like joe
is like the most underrated of the three
joe rogan joe list i joke
yeah i mean just writing salvation what
did you wrote joel is like he's so
bookish and nerdy that people are like
oh he's just like i don't know he's not
a superstar but he's like but if you eat
you son of a comedy yeah yeah
like his writing is [ __ ] great
he said eight
eight
nine that's another no that's a
did you change did it change yeah it
definitely changed you had eight or
earlier was it it wasn't like it was you
said eight there's an eight he said it
rotated
so nine then okay that's a nine it's an
eight
it's another eight it was
eight was what was announced i picked it
up
it really pulled it off it's okay
really
my turn
yeah yeah you can't
somebody roll a three i like guess who
better in the jungle you must wait until
it does try to play it with six people
yeah that's a lot you guys want to play
jumanji next
sorry my knuckles are already hairy
enough let's [ __ ] go
oh
i didn't know we had a robin in the
house
play jumanji and you have like uh
you start growing hair on your shaft i
just meant regular jumanji
it's like just a jewish guy
his name is manji
you want a plan for a fool
two
nice wheat
finally who wants sheep
who wants sheep
i need break where my brick babies at i
need wood who wants sheep for once i can
trade you would but not for sheep what
about for wheat yeah that's cool
about
one way for two wood
pawns for charisma
he's made a saving throw
it's your turn do you know what i'm
saying yes i know what you were saying
do you think our arts would be better
for culture was it like iraq war and
military industrial complex ii
i have two towns yeah let's say yeah
yeah two times
210 in common
would we be more artistic what did you
say yeah would it would our arts would
be better if our
the
what if we
reinvested
yeah we invested our energy and the
betterment
of people making people smarter and more
creative as opposed to instead of doing
the iraq war and turning and learning
find a way to be okay with that like
you're breaking your brain trying to
justify it
this and instead of doing that and
having everyone be guilty we could just
have them be like oh we're helping the
world ah what a great place and that
would be a much better
cultivator of art would anybody like jam
like raid and money does anyone have any
brick i should say no what can you mean
greed
yeah i mean you wish creates art for the
people who see you like
i got a wood and sheet for today
but then they go crazy just fighting
against it all right
that's activist versus being an artist
you gotta count your
cards one
what's so yeah so what is that
if you have more than seven you have to
give up half nah i got six
five seven nice should i get to keep
them
yeah which ones do i have to give up
anyone
that's across the board whenever
somebody hits the robber yeah
let me get one from you huh
here we go
okay
one step forward and two steps back you
got a sheep right there getting my
cheeks clapped
really uh letting the mullets sing over
there huh i feel like yeah controls
ever since it's it actually is not even
a hairstyle it's a parasite that's
snapped onto the back of my head it
controls my body
oh one step forward and two steps back
playing tan getting my cheeks clapped
do i get to look at this
don't let your babies grow up to be gay
yeah yeah this is the come down portion
of this uh yeah sure just show it stream
camera
oh all right hold on i'm not it's not
it's not working the battery died
hanzo's cable's touched
extender wasn't turned on so it wasn't
charging and then it died for the over
top
yeah
wow and i'm trying to plug it in but
it's like registering
wet right there
it's like it's wet oh [ __ ] i
there's moisture in the charging port
yeah
that's why i got a new phone because
that one is getting all [ __ ] up that's
new good
yeah it's a [ __ ] phone
it's a what it's a [ __ ] phone i
charged it with like so many different
things because i was living in my van i
charge it on my leisure battery
you're not getting a clean charge
well you know it should uh
learn how to convert it because
everything else you're done
yeah would you roll i wrote i got an 8
okay yeah my turn yeah
but i think it's also like the android
it's not good at like accepting
different things like the cord is like i
don't know
i feel like with an iphone to be able to
charge no matter what
because it's like the court is better
quality
ten
what does it mean when the robbers on a
spot means you can't pick it up you
can't pick the resource up from that
spot yeah oh really
yeah yeah
all right
i'm sorry i just didn't know what it
meant i wanted to all right i'm sorry
brother you want your brick back i want
something
you got a seven
unless you get to move the robber
let's see
let's block this
yeah
steal from brown
it's got that good steel
oh [ __ ]
so what do you think about the uh austin
comedy scene
it's cool
it's good it makes it also it feels like
everything feels very close but also so
far away if you know what i'm saying
yes you know what i'm doing right yeah
because you're in such close proximity
to so many successful people but you're
also like in the gutter gutter nitty
gritty
and i like that i like that i hate the
driving part i started out in new york
hopping on the subway was so much better
oh my god
i'm not a fan of that i'm not a fan of
like all that [ __ ] like hopping on the
silver oh i'm walking this down
the parking lot man this sucks no i'm
awesome at driving up parking i suck at
walking and getting on subways well
that's because you haven't done it if
you grew up with it it would be second
nature like driving you just lived there
for three months
i would like to go triple the amount of
spots you've hit
do you think
do you think audiences in new york are
kind of like chris i'm sorry if you go
to hit an open mic in new york do you
think the audiences are kind of prude or
stuck up with the laughs
i feel like you really don't get more
cairns than you do over here people in
austin are pretty laid back
yeah uh
higher chances of getting laid in austin
audiences
that's nice you have wood and wheat
uh
over here it's almost guaranteed at
least there's going to be like four real
people that's enough to try new jokes
yeah blew my mind like when i first
moved to austin austin comes and be like
there's only six real people at this
night [ __ ] this
that's enough dude
yeah
for sure yeah it's kind of how it is
sometimes back we have a club that does
an open mic on thursdays and sometimes
it would be like
70 people in there hell yeah dude great
place then we got another one and then
we have another one in richmond where
like i did it for the first time
i drove all the way out to the capitol
and i did it dude there was like 90
people different like on a sunday then
on a sunday bro that [ __ ] was killer and
starting to jump shoot the [ __ ]
shoot every sunday man yeah sandman
comedy club in richmond it's a good
place honestly you should check that out
you have people out there you have
people in virginia
i do like [ __ ] wife's co-workers
[Laughter]
like how many of them are gonna buy
tickets and make time in their day will
anyone trade
yeah well there's also people that find
me through tick tock anybody
willing to trade sheep foreign
[Music]
i didn't know who hans was i didn't
watch kill tony like that i didn't know
what it was and just recently found out
what kill tony was she for wheat anybody
yeah outside of l.a and austin you know
it's not well i'm not really like i'll
try not to
i saw you on instagram reels a week
before i came out here you used to put a
lot of [ __ ] on reddit i remember that
yeah seeing like your [ __ ] would show up
on on reddit a lot
brother which subreddit do you post it
to
uh late stage capitalism
[Laughter]
nature porn
so do you think it's important to feel
good or to be logical
in regards to
oh if you're a real nightmare you just
want to feel good all the time man it
doesn't matter
i mean you got to feel good or else you
lose touch of
your humanity and you start murdering
jews
but you also can't only be focused on
feeling good because then
you become gluttonous
then you
the pot of greed
anybody a lot of people couldn't handle
success
did you move the robber i moved it i
took one of hans cards and now i'm done
[Music]
let's go
one of these
does anybody need rocks
i need rocks what do you have i'm [ __ ]
i'm literally two settlements deep or
like you want shape
i mean i suppose what do you want rock
how many two
i can do one okay i'll do one
i'll give you hay
here's the thing about ron's he only
rolls charisma once and if you deny it
then he agrees
honestly it wasn't a fair trade to give
you
a sheet for two rocks oh
hey what do you want to do
two i can only do one i'll do a shoot
for a rock
all right
you want to shoot for a rock
sheep rock yeah
no i'm good no i'll just she won't shoot
for
four
brick
brick
brick
trying to build a settlement i'm trying
to settle [ __ ]
i got a bad [ __ ] sucking on the tip of
my dick
lean back in my whip nine
pulling up to six
bumping six
pretty good
night
i want sheep
what about two sheep for one rock
i'll do it
oh michael was a cutie thanks dude
so do you think like michael thanks
do you think like east asians have a
hard time
[Music]
do you think east asians have a harder
time feeling good and
our southeast asians have a harder time
thinking logical
yeah i have a really good time feeling
good that's why i'm the fattest asian
out of all three of us
my bmi is higher than your guys have you
ever been fat that's also why your gdp
is
a tenth of korea's
well here's the thing filipinos we we're
uh we're a physical laborer you know
we're
people we're mexicans of asia yeah we
work real hard
but is it true or is it just because
colonization and the lack of arable land
and
humidity that prevents like
certain types of industries from forming
i guess that would yeah i mean that
makes sense i don't think it's genetic i
think it's just kind of geographic
[ __ ] are just you know although
you're asking for inputting
uh yeah ginger white guy how do you feel
about this i mean they're all hand tight
i mean they're all homies i mean they're
oh what'd you have seven seven yeah
i have plenty of asian houses
let me get one of yours
have you ever been fat huh no
not not even when you're a kid that's
fine no
hans do you like bulgogi yeah
do you know where you where can we get
i have sheep you have rock no no i have
sheep i need rotten
or wheat
a wheat i will trade sheep for a week
it's a good snack
okay
i'm gonna
can i play a development card on my turn
yeah as long as you didn't pick it up
just now no i've had this one
yes
um
hey let me get one of yours
so do you think like socializing is an
important part oh no stand up or do you
think like you can not do it and still
be really good at stand up and just
not really get good at making friends
and [ __ ] you think you're just gonna
get booked
yeah but what if you're like brian
reagan
he didn't socialize
he doesn't have to anymore
no well not now yeah but i mean in the
first five six years just to get booked
you need to be friends with everyone
but
what if you just get good at it i'm
pretty sure and you can avoid all that
well killed
i wasn't a good sister that's just what
you tell yourself
i wasn't a good socializer
yeah
stay tuned thank you
no i mean
yeah i mean i think i got better at
socializing and now i'm like a i'm
really good at conversations uh you got
to i mean i'm sure he's been like a
social person
comedy
yeah i got good how do you think coming
to austin helped you does anyone want to
trade a sheep for a rock i mean everyone
here is looking for a rocker you're
looking for everyone's so happy to be
here you can't talk about it no one's
like being forced to be here besides
like you know
wives
yeah casey
casey rocket now
uh yeah everyone's happy to be here
that's the good thing about austin it's
like we're all like oh my god it's open
you know like we can do comedy
we we're just in a pandemic and like
nothing was working
oh dude just give me your cards before
you pass out man no it's cool
your face is purple what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you oh dude i think he's on
heroin are you sick
did you not have enough light
i did i couldn't tell yeah it was
actually simple enough to check my ears
i don't know well i'm sitting on this
side of you so your face did look dark
over here oh so legit was like nervous
for a second because i'm like i thought
he died
that's all i roll is eight i've rolled
like [ __ ] seven oh you got the
longest road who's green me
oh that's a long road
that's the longest road thanks bud
what are you reaching for
so you've got like five points right now
man actually
yep
longest road holy [ __ ] nick you do
we should cop some katan we should
copper
set one of these up back home but we can
play some canton
asians love cat
cats
i think you joke about the cats
was that [ __ ] cats or something
you said dude you said something about
[ __ ] cats bro yeah something yeah
some cats of asians yeah you made it
sounded bad like [ __ ] cats was wrong
or something yeah
yeah i don't have our fetishes man
oh it's my turn
five
all right all
joseph's joke was so funny about child
molestation which one the one with the
kid on the tinder profile no the one
where he's like i ran into my ex and it
had been such a long time she changed
completely she even grew breasts now
versions of kittens so
my favorite joke of his was uh
what'd you roll uh
i wrote a five
oh [ __ ] i don't want to butcher that man
oh well i shouldn't do it on stone again
no he'd be happy
well hold on i still gotta trade and
build [ __ ]
uh
he's such a word smith
you have to be if you're a one miner
he is
a wordsmith so he became a one-liner
if he was a wordsmith and he did like
rambling
[ __ ] stories can i get uh
everybody's bricks please i don't have
any
what is it
bricks monopoly card oh really what did
you roll chris yeah i rolled a five oh
it's five
i feel like maybe because i have houses
i have two i have two is that all your
bricks
hell yes
damn
you boys have any bricks i don't know
i don't know i'll give you something um
can i get some stone too
you're playing another you can only play
one [ __ ] now you guys know
he's gonna trade you so soon for a break
buddy for a brick
i'll trade this whole sheet
i'll show you some sheep for one of my
bricks back hold on
build one of these bad boys
like
i hope somebody hits you with a robber
so you gotta give up a bunch of your
cards
do you guys think like i pick up a lot
of chicks
dude that's every
tony interview you have
well a lot of it's been about how i'm
not picking up tricks
yeah but you still get made out with by
strippers and stuff all the time it's
been a while you probably get your
little victories here dude what are you
doing
you gotta show the story right i saw the
flyer i'm not even pursuing that i don't
think you're actually you don't have to
but you wrote six just by association i
think you get your victories here and
there but you're not [ __ ] actively
clapping cheeks like every single night
not yet
that's where i hope to be soon
just clapping cheeks and just being like
i don't even want [ __ ] anymore
hans i'm telling you let's make a yellow
fever shift
[Music]
let's do it it's a dating stand-up show
dude i think that could crush
i don't want to make it seem to make a
wishy to where we like don't look like
we get laid but uh no
do any of you have i mean i already have
it
for trade yeah i don't know i don't want
that just asian show i want a stand-up
show okay yeah i want to say
or we could just do improvisations eight
improvisations
we are asian and doing improv all at the
same time yeah i'm disappointing our
parents
we're a triple threat
will anyone trade sheep for weeks
we'll trade
what's up dick for [ __ ]
you know if you have over seven cards in
a seven year old you have to give up
half
yeah
it was an eight
i don't know
it was an eight that's a good fun fact
is anybody willing to trade sheep for
wheat or sheep for rock
[Music]
so
do you feel like you sing and like hum
and burp and fart like any time like
they're what it's like
wrong
it doesn't feel good you gotta feel it
you gotta maintain your feeling goodness
i'm trying to move
a little better calling you a narcissist
dude really oh you're nauseous no i'm
telling you like you have to feel good
asian east asians we can feel bad like
oh i'm a piece of [ __ ] my dick's tiny
oh speak
but like some people they just can't and
they just feel good another eight
another eight i feel like it's good to
have that because it's mentally more
healthy your brain is in healthier
chemicals than like oh i'm a piece of
[ __ ] this is my add man i'll just make
sounds anyone have any brick for trade i
think this is great you make your own
i try to i i like manifest [ __ ] i
believe in like i speak things into
existence
why why does it matter because there's
too much magical thinking
i actually um
i did it for the lulz
yeah actually because i knew it wasn't
gonna happen like i knew he wasn't gonna
win so i just i just wanted the video of
the pen like scribbling the square that
said trump so you did it for the i need
some wheat maybe yeah yeah yeah wow
voted actually i want for a week i don't
know what you mean what do you mean i
think the ironically vote for trump is
better than writing in scooby-doo or
kanye
[Music]
yeah you have to do it like that you
can't go like this
like palm it oh no that's not nice
that's like the whole plate you gotta
take just just take wait
are you palming a whole thing of rice
how hungry are you
how much tagalog do you know
[Music]
i yes after watching three hours of uh
jo koy's specials i might know more than
you
hindi
means no you don't
hinde
oppo all right just roll
in the mall tell
manny pacquiao is pretty funny he said a
lot of cool stuff about gay people
i'm gonna move this
all the gays should die um
what do i need here well if you're a
boxer and you're
chapelle said that yeah some people in
the face why would it matter
that's your mentality you're like what's
the problem that's a problem can i punch
it move the robber steal one resource
from the owner of a settlement
orange or white you can see it from
mumford to chris you get to choose
show me your hands let's fan them out
fan those [ __ ] cards out what do you
want what do you want dude i need jesus
give me a hand somebody hit hey
he choose play the knight give me the
chooser he didn't roll seven no so no
one has to get
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right i'm gonna move this [ __ ] first
um
[ __ ] dude green and blue who are you
gonna take from one clue
we gotta give up half our cards if we're
over seven yeah
you rolled the seven yep
i liked richmond i thought it was a
little bit small like the scene wasn't
that big
yeah the people that were super nice i
hung out with uh
that lady do you remember that lady that
i hung out with actually i stayed at her
house it was a movie what did she look
like she was older but attractive this
car yeah
yeah i stayed at her house and we hung
out i never [ __ ] we never fight oh yeah
yo no [ __ ] i feel like hans could
have secured that too you could have
secured yeah i only rolled for charisma
i know
so
uh do you like katan never heard of it
okay
like you could have clapped bro
you gotta roll you gotta try again roll
twice i just don't
want to it's like pursue
like meet me halfway
you know across the sky make me rape you
yeah i know what you mean
you gotta buy a settlement first that's
good that you prefer like oh i do you
prefer i only have sex with people that
really want to have sex that's what i'm
saying
i hope so dude if you don't if you're
not like a hundred percent about it it's
probably not gonna he's not gonna sell
it he's not gonna sell
sex
yeah
he wants you to
you have to come into the store like
looking for it
he's not going to be like hey what's
going on let me know if you guys need
anything yeah
that's it
isn't that sales guy yeah i'm just in
the guy going door to door being like
he's the person who's today
the person comes in and they're like i
got like three grand and i really want
to buy this phone and hans is like oh
wow
the one you're looking for yeah that's
probably why i only [ __ ] the crazy
[ __ ]
they're looking around the bar
frantically and their tunnel vision just
closes in on hans and he's sitting in
the corner just smiling
yeah i mean i don't know i'm a [ __ ] i
guess
it's okay
i guess
ted
yes i just gotta go out there and get
rejected more
do you not talk to the girls after shows
like do they not come up to you and be
like you're so funny like that's all
you've seen it happen
that's all you need dude i mean i
i'm trying
[Laughter]
and then eventually i [ __ ] it up
somewhere ah
like i had one girl come in here and we
were making out the whole time and it
was great and then
we were making out in here and touching
your breasts and she was like i gotta go
i gotta go what she just left did she
fart or did you
i think it's because i was moving too
slow
i think we were making it how long were
y'all making out for for like you know
we made out at the bar then we made out
in the car that we made out here and
then i think she was like i need this to
move a little faster but instead of
saying that she's like i'm just going to
leave how long did y'all make out for it
you got to close bro you got to be able
to close like 10 minutes half an hour i
teach them to close
i don't need to be taught too close i
just need
we started making out i'd say two
minutes is enough i know but it's like
whatever she is feeling is too much it
was too much for her and then she just
decided to leave but instead of just
leaving want to just say hey
can you listen
honestly
like instead of just being like oh it's
too long why don't you just like
communicate that yeah
it's awkward but yeah i mean she was
pawning up oh my god
yeah it's like
don't just leave
like if you're willing to communicate
that i'm leaving like isn't it easier to
communicate that
we should be moving faster
that's for usually that's what we're
just like [ __ ] me
[ __ ] me hans nine but she didn't want
she didn't say that she did oh okay so
then you kind of have to take the wheel
at that point buddy i know but she just
left
can't even give me that piss me off
big swollen blue yellow balls
yeah blue yellow balls green balls blue
yellow balls green balls yeah i mean i
should do better but also like they
should communicate it's her fault
it's no one's fault but perfect
there's things that can be easily done
like [ __ ]
yeah
to avoid that situation
sure someone's been going to therapy
that's good
yeah i would have been so pissed
will anyone trade rock
for brick
no
no way
rock for a brick no
all right
yeah
yeah no or yeah yeah
no no i have a rock i need a bridge oh
no you're you're on drums
it's uh robot three three thank you so i
can finally collect on three
yes i finally can get brick i got a rack
i come from my rest
i rock
like a rack
a brick
and
a wood and build another road
towards the ocean i'm trying to get the
ocean from
love i want a port
here we go
you from the ocean yeah
in the ocean
i'm done
i should probably be trading more
i have trouble communicating yeah
it's okay
that's right yeah i have to go to the
bathroom really bad though go pee pee
mom no no no i'm gonna miss collecting
my resources it's true okay all right
we'll just uh steal them for you don't
do that
we'll keep
do you want us to pause like hold the
game while you go to play let's have a
conversation keep it going let's keep
talking don't be so mad
what'd you roll dude what'd you roll
fine what is it hey i made the cup seven
i made the cup
sorry
jesus hans stacking him up damn man
after all that [ __ ] he gave me like nine
minutes ago
you gotta move the robber
where are you gonna move it
hold on okay
get your shirt
four
four
yeah you gotta put it somewhere we can
all see it so we know you're not lying i
know
it was a four though that's why i'm so
sad
[Music]
i'm brad says as soon as you get home
hans stop making out and get naked
yeah bro
zero to sixty zero to sixty too much who
rolled what would you roll i rolled up
four too much making out for what you
signaled that you don't want anything
besides second base
[Laughter]
jesus christ
damn tony
well you know like if she stuck around
maybe there would have been more yeah
the girl would have gotten that right
we got in that hans
she was getting her hands all over her
making out shouldn't take as long as a
catan game
[Laughter]
hey man this is the sex this isn't the
foreplay all right
you know it was really awesome how we
were making out so i wanted more of that
and then i got a little distracted but
you know like something's happening that
you don't like just mention it give it
give me a shout out he was like hey do
you have enough resources to build this
road yeah my bro i'm brad as a total
alpha he's in what you're making out
he's in one or four i need all the the
bricks from y'all
[ __ ] not again
that's fine
that's fine orange beard
over here [ __ ] huh
uh you were raised right you guys got
anybody
i don't know whatever you said oh yeah
thanks
once you're making out and fondling
she's down or she'd be macing you that
is a very valid point six
well yeah i mean it's like
you can [ __ ] her and then it'll be great
but
i wanted to make out some more
hans is a romantic he needed time to get
hard yeah that's what
i'm talking about
hell yeah brother
he had to he had to pump it up like
reebok yeah that's fair that's fair he
had to pump it up it's like four players
for man there's a lot for the girls for
the guy to charge up my wife gets mad
because i don't do any foreplay because
i have you
i have the libido of a [ __ ] 13 year
old my dick just gets instantly harder
to seven uh do i eat ass yes does she
like it no
how many cards you got there guys she
doesn't like she's a kinky girl does she
like you guys got more than seven cards
nope
my wife is a she's good she's trad i
have a trad wife
sure what that was trash
no one has more than seven cards how
many cards you got you never heard of
trad wife
are you sure you don't have eight
you just took all of our bricks
[ __ ] that's a good call good job
[Laughter]
[Music]
tony says hans is a pro edger
it's just one instance
yeah is it bothering you
are you getting pissed we can change
gears all right now i'm going to take
one of your cards just like her and her
crazy way and she was a little she was a
heckling you didn't get rid of half of
them she was yeah she was heckling which
show
spider house
and um she was a little crazy
but she was hot as [ __ ]
put her in her place tell her shut up
yeah i had a good time
i'd rather it have happened than not but
yeah
she was a little weird about
just leaving in the middle of it
it is a weird flex
because there was more
action
that was going to happen
i lost a jewel
[Music]
i wish we could smoke cigarettes inside
i think you can
no i can't can't you uh
will anyone trade a
wood for
wheat or raw fruit yes
wood for wheat or rock i'll take raw
i'll cherry wood for wheat
oh wait i have wood oh i need a rock
so this girl
told me
you don't have to be good looking i'm
attracted to minds
what she's a sapiosexual distracted mind
but don't call me ugly too
no that means she's saying she got
yellow fever dude mm-hmm no she said
i'm not that attractive but i have a
cool mind which is great but
also i'd like to be attractive as well
do you watch asian male white female
porn no
is it good
yeah kinda
if your girls are hot they're girls the
girls are high but if the dick is
smaller than yours you feel embarrassed
it's not good but also good you're
making us look bad
it isn't good for the cause no yeah
there's something like pencil dicks on
there for sure sure it's not me
if anything i should know yeah if
anything i should be making it i'm
starting
we need to start a positive male body
image
12. dude yeah you got to be 12.
you're the asian sex symbol is that
asian dudes with giant dicks on a
calendar um
there is one dude he's a korean dude and
he's like washboard abs and a nine inch
cup
yeah
see there we go
we have one dude
he's a korean dude he's got like long
hair and he [ __ ] bangs hella [ __ ]
but the bad part is it's like
most of the videos are him getting head
and he's getting his ass and you're like
oh
what's wrong with that i think it's a
family he's erotic i think it's a
feminine if you if you're a dude as the
first asian guy you can't be going for
the artistic point
you gotta be slinging
jeremy
you gotta open that glass ceiling yeah
you gotta like gash ceiling you gotta
like [ __ ] put [ __ ] in the suplex
have you ever seen the suplex i'm not
12.
that's nice
of the
the full nelson the full nail center
wait what'd you what'd you roll 12.
yeah make her do a handstand while you
eat her blood blue has 12. and then um
does anybody want to trade
who's got wheat that they want to get
worried about i literally just need one
week what do you need anyone with wheat
what are you three rocks
three rocks for one wheat two weeds for
three rods a wood
a wood i have one wood i'll do one wood
for a wheat
all right
i'm gonna build a city
can i build a city right now yeah okay
thank you [ __ ] a brown's coming up in
the world y'all little browns that's a
little so i can build this anywhere yeah
i can put this into a settlement on my
settlements
yeah replace one of the houses with that
okay
god damn it
yeah there you go
brown's coming up in the world us little
browns
big browns
oh you uh
okay he's in real time
nice like an asian guy with a white trad
wife is good
she you know she manages the books and
all that good [ __ ] yeah they're really
roasting the [ __ ] out of this curtain
somebody said meth lab curtain
they said that they think it's only
because you're in front of the curtain
does she like to be slapped good cook
great question i'm asking the real
question
that they hope that you're charging us
to hang out with you yeah i just read
that i just saw that one the what
charges us with our time they said hans
is so much cooler than these guys
dude the board game was his idea
i think we just drank the conversation
hey do you guys want to come over and
play katan
yeah sometimes you sound like this
i don't think i sound like that what are
you talking about
i'm hans kim
sorry every white girl now
all the white girls sound like that hi
i'm hans kidd hey what's going on yeah
all the white girls do sound like that
now
what's going on hans you were so funny
let's make out
hans you are hilarious tonight let's
make out i'll let you finger my uh
[ __ ]
and then i'll dip
really funny stuff dude
[ __ ] bulge brushing against your knee
how many uh female comics in austin have
come up to you like that
really good stuff dude
oh my god dude i'm [ __ ] sorry i'm
laughing so hard my face i don't think i
[ __ ] any austin comics you don't want
to
you haven't no
damn bro give me give me a card baby
what you want [ __ ]
i know
you want you yeah what'd you roll i
rolled a six what do you want six in the
chinese dog
all right baby all right now we're
cooking chinese people always taking
resources from the philippines
you're so greedy hey i didn't know where
you were are you done
you're done yeah i'm in spain without
the six
let's go
i got that austin coven dude this is
what happens when you have a bunch of
rednecks doing environmental policies
and planning and plant all the wrong
trees in the wrong area that's what this
game is right now no allergies oh this
is yeah austin coveted just out i was
like yeah all the whites over here were
like man we can't get anything off this
board
that green screen really tells the room
together
is still your turn yeah
real trailer park vibe with the sheet
all right so how do we so how do i like
can i build out this way and this way
because you can't like go
dude i'm brad you're a homie dude that
i'm brad is a real one everyone knows
candy
you can build whatever direction
yeah
[Music]
that dude's beating off the banana fever
on pornhub yes but can i put like this
solid can i put roads the guy's got that
weird yeah but you can't build your head
over [ __ ] that's what i thought okay
like why are you stamping
japanese i don't mind that the stamping
is weird i don't like the whole like on
your face
i
his fingers kind of like a pencil like
do you not that i could do a better job
i don't know if i was [ __ ] like you
wouldn't be doing hazel more for 12
minutes i i i can't do that but i
wouldn't last long man it's hard that's
a hard
you gotta think about it those dudes
[ __ ] hot [ __ ] all day long and
then they have to hold their nut no but
then they get desensitized if you
[ __ ] well then they start loving it
again
and then they they're like this is the
best job in the world because you're
just getting really good cardio and you
just get to [ __ ] hot [ __ ] all day
long you go to the gym does anybody have
a brick for trade you exercise break no
trading break it's so hard to get i
don't know why brick is such a hard one
it's difficult
to obtain
hell yeah it said hans is right blame
the whites
what was the name of that guy
i'm brad again oh it's great singers
what did i say about the whites
uh you said it was their fault
it was a four sorry i said that
for the pollen
they probably had the red trees yeah
they're really nice
it wasn't like this when the native
americans were here are you sure there
were so many buffalo what if there would
have been
so many buffalo until the californians
came to austin there was buffalo for
miles
the united nations i think where we are
they were more regular
we could smell them because we didn't
have so much more rigs we don't know
that we could smell them because
there's so many goddamn homeless people
what's happened to my
what's happened to my true
appropriating my culture is anyone
willing to trade
does anyone want to trade wood for wheat
i was outside i had orange juice i would
like some wheat
how much
i'll trade two wood for two wheat i'll
give you one wheat all right
for two wood no one wait for one wood
okay
god damn i was outside of the arch
building i saw a guy beating off under
an aids
how to make a woman
happy give her a massage
what is that thing called sore muscles
there i got it
the [ __ ] blaster 5000. i could actually
get it on amazon
30 bones on amazon it's called my uh
yeah thanks for taking the curtain down
hans has said [ __ ] this no it's nice i
like it don't let brad and the others
tell you what show off those bottles
don't let them see that yeah bro you
guys want to see some tito's six shots
nine
let's go
shots boys yo
shots
yeah trade wood fellas yeah they like it
when we trade wood the butt puncher 3000
i do i would i have to put
i put that thing on your [ __ ] on your
glutes bro
you walk around for a while you walk
around you got a sore ass
from michael ridley that's what i'm
saying that's funny
massage those cheeks you know what i'm
saying
but anyone want to trade does anyone
need sheep
cheap yeah uh cheap you might want some
livestock on your
yeah yes
um yeah a rock for sheep
oh you know there's nine yeah i rolled a
nine oh
thank you nine she dude are you trying
to cheat does that mean
yeah you want me to yeah which one you
want baloney
are there any more stars for me
blast my butt cheat chris
[Applause]
hey hey come on man you're in my brown
eye dude oh thank you that was good well
i said blood cheek not massage my ass
hey man you lick your wife's ass i know
you're kinky yeah i know i pulled a
hamstring can you do me now
oh wow that's amazing oh dude that's
about
[Applause]
we're gonna get flags
get the nipple too
a lot of muscles on the nipple yeah get
those milk duds working bro
thank you yeah
i appreciate that homie okay hang on yes
oh don't yeah don't do that that would
have been [ __ ] catastrophic
you want some of this verde i'll do a
tito's baby momento
hans you got some good folk in here man
are there any more why are they good in
the youtube yeah oh nice i always take
them for granted
no green 22. okay so yeah they don't
want the green all 22 no green screen
until we figure it out but you had the
green screen set up but didn't know how
to change it
it would be cool if it was an aquarium
and there you could see fish swimming oh
behind us
like sharks like a shark or just big
booty latinas like twerking
yeah yeah yeah just a twerk compilation
playing in the
[Music]
he has a video of me sitting on stage
with all the people and i think you
should gain all the [ __ ]
they were just strippers i would hate if
my daughter did that yeah
that is a sin against man and you wanna
do you want to be a father
i want to be a grandfather okay
[Laughter]
so yeah
check this out somebody
he looked like he was trying to bid on
taking somebody
[Music]
well they were at a tiebreaker and i
thought it would have been really funny
if they like we're going to asians work
on the asian to determine who wins the
torque battle at vulcan because they
were like we we don't do no ties around
here somebody's going to take home this
thousand dollars
all your solutions i thought that's what
they did i thought they were twerking on
purpose
there was only two girls that they're
twerking like the whole time yeah i
thought they sent the blue haired girl
yeah and i liked the bigger one so she
won a thousand dollars
one girl took her pants off and started
touching her butthole on stage but the
other girl they were louder
i think the whole event one of them
looks like lanell were they hot
one was lanelle and
one was wearing one little [ __ ] one had
a third wing the blue hair oh okay okay
yeah so okay so one looked like lanell
and the other one looked like thing one
and thing two from cat in the hat it's
kind of hot well she was wearing a red
jacket she was wearing a red jacket and
she had a blue wig and she took she
peeled her paintings down and like
slapped her butthole with her middle
finger in front of everybody yeah yeah
it was lit
she was doing this number at her buckle
dude i told you about the broom closet
it smelled well
yeah they [ __ ] in the broom clothes
smell a little bit it smelled good
very good
i know what to do with this room i know
where the spots are
a lot of people throw up in there now
yeah because they smell hanza's [ __ ]
fest in the closet
so you won't have any alcohol no are you
sleepy man
you're asian i know
do you get red uh oh
i look right
sometimes i get purple look your flies
down what an idiot
my micro penis
no
unless it's really big though just a
casual way for me to show it off
oh
no
yeah i definitely got nervous there for
a minute because i thought you actually
turned purple it's your boy michael
you're a genius you got that microphone
close to purple dude no i'm like white
from over here yeah alarming like your
head turned a different video any
siblings momford i got a little sister
bro does got a sister oh you say
something i meant your [ __ ] you guys
he's 26. he's 26 yeah she was just out
here
oh yeah that's cody myers saw her at
creek we went to greek in the cave i was
taking her to the mics and [ __ ] and he
was like who's the lady you have here
i'm like that's my sister
yeah you don't want to say something
like oh you're from virginia you
probably sleep yeah yeah it was i was
trying to prevent those jokes from
hiding
dude i'm not alive
[Music]
everybody in the scene he would be the
one to get caught with cp i had to block
out here yeah maybe no i'm just saying
in general
i don't want to do i don't know if he
would get caught it's he has a face but
i don't know
and i'm saying in general like people
always like coming from virginia people
always make that [ __ ] yeah
i'm kind of tired of it i'm trying to
tell you you're from virginia what do
you [ __ ] your kids in i'm like no none
of them live people say that [ __ ] about
texas man none of them live there okay
[ __ ] weirdos asian people commit
incest as well
yeah when you peek and you let the
toilet seat up yeah you [ __ ] see
[ __ ] scoundrels or next time sit down
and use the squatty potty i pulled it up
i pulled the seat up but i put it down
because i didn't know if there was going
to be a lady
put it back down
like you have to have any company you
got to make a point there was
there's no point no there was someone
here last night and in case she was here
again i don't want her to fall in
yeah i don't get the idea of that like
girl
i couldn't close the deal with her
either i rolled the 12 you guys [ __ ]
nice i get more sheep
so much sheep
anyone want to trade a sheep for
something
i'm going to do a sheep another resource
yeah
i want to get rid of a sheep does anyone
need like six sheep no you could trade
in four of any one resource for
one of another reason why are you
helping him wait i can do that at any
time
that's what all these are you should
learn the rules at least well i forgot
one of them
but do you have to be butted up to the
ports to do that yeah yeah no ports are
two to one right
so some of them are
you just need a settlement somewhere so
at any time i can trade in four yeah
anytime you get all these [ __ ] sheep
hans can i have a miller yeah thanks
baby
nobody needs the sheets okay
i gotta i gotta turn it up dude
oh that's right [ __ ] no i'm just here
for good times
[Laughter]
i mean
i'm like one of the smartest people at
work
i am they're [ __ ] struggling blue
color
yeah but you know i do a lot of big
brain moves at work and [ __ ]
this game has nothing to do with
intelligence
it's sheer luck 11. i just like the
colors don't be a dummy i mean i don't
think it's that important to get good at
this game i'm just saying like
does anybody have wood
i have wood what do you want
set it again what do you want
what do you have to trade for my wood i
mean what do you need
um i don't want to just make it easy
what do you need a fat black [ __ ] for
this one
give me some thick old gash dump this
without any of these 16's you got any
wheat wait did we roll in 11 uh yeah
yeah yeah i can do a wheat for wood you
want two wood for two wheat
um no i want one wheat for one wood all
right i'm good on that i'll trade your
baby settlement created
achievement unlocked
suck my [ __ ] asian dick and lick my
[ __ ] ass pal
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's like you know what hans i'm not
going to lose this game
you got to put on
a savage seat
chris what's your last name
christine the savage
guess then he's gonna do it again yeah
oh my god you'll strike again all right
so where can i i can put this anywhere
anywhere you want anywhere i want no no
what do you have you gotta build a road
first calm down you can change your you
got to build the road you can change out
your one set like
you can build a road build right now
we're all friends you can swap this for
the settlement though
wait what swap what for this can you
build a road right now
yes i guess we're not [ __ ] building
[ __ ] you already paid for the settlement
times take the money back that you've
paid
don't take the money back pay for the
road please
all right chancellor house chancellor
hans has spoken pay for the road
wood
brick suck my asian dick
doesn't have to be an asian dick can it
just be a normal dick no because it's
better
asian dick is like saying
like norwegian wood
[Laughter]
all right where
tell me where to go
not there
that's the only place you can go
you can go there but you can't build a
settlement right now
i recommend going here here and they
pour it there
thank you chris
well then take back
a sheep and uh
i already had put it i didn't put it
down yet i didn't divvy up the resources
and they're still in my hands what can
you build another
what does this say i love another three
to one no i cannot okay brick is really
hard to get right now dude do you have
to put like
we're having like real supply chain
issues
embargo that's all i [ __ ] hear trade
war that's all i hear at work we can't
really get that right now because of
kovid
do you need a settlement excuse me
yeah collector you do yeah ten
peeing in the dark there's a 99 chance
he didn't wash his hands no entirely
yeah if you used a little bit of soap
are you vaccinated
got boosted a month ago no who's here
who here isn't vaccinated me
yeah
and you're gonna get herpes
sorry yeah hey man
it's just me and you yeah let's make out
i mean
i thought we already did you know what
you did you know what you're doing to
the community at large and yourself i've
actually gotten covered four times so i
think i'm good
yeah i've gotten covered like four times
i think i'm fine you know if anything
they would need me to make the vaccine
so
um
they need my blood i don't have anything
if your vaccine works
for anybody yeah if your vaccine works
hans then that's good what did he
wrongly play in a [ __ ] car thank you
did you roll the dice yeah hook me up
man help me close chris did you roll the
dice yeah i rolled a 10. somebody wrote
seven
i hit 10. i'm brad says hans will win
hanzo
what do you need
i played a monopoly card no [ __ ] so i
have to give you all of mine i can get
all the monopoly cards i don't know
[Music]
i like all this racism
stop all the yellow on yellow crime am i
right we got a korean
chinese filipino
how do you feel about that yeah my dad's
black i don't like it man that sounds
like world war three over here did you
guys believe in like bobby's bobby lee's
hierarchy of asians you got the trees
tree asians jungle asians my ancestors
he like broke down the flow charts
[Laughter]
put down a rock you don't need a rock
for a settlement oh [ __ ] i looked at it
wrong that's what you need to wait for
stealing on a rock you give it back did
you put down a wood too yeah i did okay
okay
because
hans you're you're uh youtube chat
people are funny under the right
circumstances would you ever good all 13
of them very funny
would you ever smoke crack under the
right circumstances under 35.
i smoked meth before really i was how
was it it was good it was a little manic
a little manicure
how long how long did you experience
like a good positive energy and then it
like you know it's like i feel like you
were probably like pretty hyper before
you did that why are you taking the
sheet back
because um
uh what color was it even smarter what
color was the math i don't remember
probably white so somebody offered me
man recorded somebody offered me to
record it yeah wow [ __ ] yeah dude and it
was blue it was the blue meth from
breaking two of these cards it's not a
monopoly but like yeah ooh just like on
tv
somebody offered me blue myth and i went
ooh just like tv and i was like you know
what i probably shouldn't do this
because i'm like
it's like it's like it's trendy
it's cool to smoke blue meth as long as
it looks like the mouth from breaking
bad you're fine yeah that looks good
that's a good mouth seven
oh [ __ ] moving moving the old robber
please don't choose orange
julia roberts
just take me out of the game
put me in this give me your cards rape
me
rape
[Music]
yeah i
wish going to yeah chris
what do you want
what do you want
[ __ ]
[Music]
yeah
i pissed in the dark i didn't know why
would you not turn the light on what
year is this is there any way can we get
a hanzo a day
yeah dude
you should have killed yourself
you should've done you i love you dude i
bet you [ __ ] mad [ __ ] with a bidet
thanks man they'd be like anytime
that'd be a great segue to ana keep that
keep that boy [ __ ] clean [ __ ] love
[ __ ] love the days
spritz the cooch
puns is that eight points now let it
loose
away
yeah it looks landlocked five six wait i
already put it here yes you did rape me
freeze scared he's scared of the
toilet pisser
katan meth
meth smokers of catan
go ahead aunt
another shot
11 11 let's go
let's go
i know you koreans like to drink let's
go
okay hans i'll do it love it
i love it love it love it
who is this
shot glasses for once in our trip i'm
not [ __ ] driving so i'm like yeah
let's go well you drove all the way here
from virginia no we flew but i got the
rental and i put in my name and i've
been driving all the boys
got that mental fort port i hate being
the driver i got a fortuitous mind chris
give you about six tries to get that
word but i believe you
two twice
fortuitous nature
what's your role
are you mad at me
hey hans do you think girl comedians are
funny
some of them all these [ __ ] it's hard
for them because they're getting so
distracted
[Laughter]
i asked him if he was mad at me and then
he said well i've got all these [ __ ]
accusing me that i pissed on the toilet
which i did and then at least it's not
an accusation
i did it but i'm still mad that they're
okay all right let's go let's go with
five
i'm gonna throw the knight down i think
girl comedians can be funny but they're
they just get so easily distracted by
trying to look as hot as possible chris
let me get one of yours it's just too
alluring they'd rather look hot than be
funny well back home we have this thing
where it's like it doesn't matter how
funny you are you just [ __ ] the guy who
is fine with me
that lasts for a little bit but it does
it doesn't feel good if you're up on a
great show that your boyfriend got you
on and then you're bombing yeah
no dick for you
anyone's willing to trade
i have i have wood
is anyone willing to trade it for either
way
do you ask any girl would you rather be
attractive or funny and they're always
going to be choosing attractive
guys
i mean uh every time
it's a shitty game is anyone willing to
trade wood for stone
for stone
trade use some wood and get some stone
yeah wood for rock i got wood you got
stone yeah i'll give you a wood for a
stone no [ __ ]
the other way around
no green but yeah i mean i think can we
agree that when you say trade you're
leading with what you've got like you're
[Laughter]
my friend is your true it's so hard to
get funny that if there's any
distractions on the road there you're
gonna take it and like
it to a girl like looking attractive is
way more prominently say that again it's
so hard to get funny so any distractions
you're going to take right along the way
it's like over time
if you don't have all your [ __ ] figured
out all right buddy think about that now
i don't know appreciate the ugly girls
think about how many guys you [ __ ] on
the road yeah i know modford stuff
[ __ ]
stop
[Applause]
no more distractions no more
distractions right
yes
it's all about what kind of girl you
[ __ ] on the road
yeah stop i should stop [ __ ] dudes
and
start [ __ ] stuff yeah
it's okay hey
i didn't want to shoot
he forced me yeah yeah i know that's the
kind of
yeah this is the kind of woman's need in
your life i don't know i don't think
that's just one victory point two nights
[ __ ]
what does that mean six is still my turn
so i i'm gonna build a settlement
uh with one
guy what is a victory
for the
and the knights don't hold any weight
in our
feelings sucking on my dick where you
sucking on my balls
oh yeah
he's got a victory point as the card so
he has one two three four five six seven
eight points
[Music]
oh man crazy rich asians
even flew
[Music]
[Music]
give it up for caleb
hey beard gang gets a very thin
beer gang it's a beer thing uh anybody
who wants a chicken you want to trade
stone
for a wood
no or a hay
hey
i had i you know i was in the lead for
like a minute
and then hans built his road i'll play
one of my nights you don't want to go
down
he
that
a great wall that rod
fan out those hands steal from red i
guess
no it's actually tied oh really he's
almost losing it's like
yes
[Laughter]
uh do you guys think that caleb looks
like the white version of hans
holy [ __ ] somebody's talking about it
before you guys have like the same head
shape
but somebody changed the race yeah yeah
yeah i think we're here
he also
eight years same oh hell yeah
what am i
yeah it's good though i'm proud of it oh
yeah these people go this rough town
yeah you know it's a lot of speeding
tickets it's nothing serious murder and
speeding tables that's like their main
exports
nice
yeah come after you buddy he's coming
for me dude i don't even feel it right
now
for you
it's about to bust all over your booty
hole bro this is like the lord
like the sequel of the korean war right
now lord have mercy i'm about to bust
are you korean i'm doing a good job
right okay you're keeping up wonderfully
i believe it was china versus korea my
history is a little bit off oh yeah the
korean one yeah yeah
it's a water bottle i'm brad
[Music]
see if your wife gets jealous in here
well she will if you put it right here
you're a little stizzy
who wants bricks
i don't want y'all to help me just don't
help him
i'll trade you
uh
are you serious oh wait you're so red
right now
you can see i in the camera i need two
you gotta not hit it like a cigarette
you gotta hit like a hookah
longest road then uh hold back
what about any water
oh wait
and
at this point of hans what's the game
i'm like all right it's fine
he's like dude you guys want to come to
my house and watch me play this game i'm
really good at
the rest of you [ __ ] mouth breathers
the people are upset because they can't
see the board who wants wood
i have that got wood i need wheat who
has wheat and wants wood i do
you have weight
yep can i have it don't give he's like i
don't care who wins as long as how many
uh more wood do you need
that's it
do you need a break
break
hold this on the tip of your dome piece
for as long as possible
put on your muscles
yeah whoever knocks versus them
you have weeds
[Laughter]
you can't
you want brick yeah do you have wheat
shotty
yeah yeah yeah yeah
do you have another thing
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
well you can use them to buy other stuff
you can combine it don't
selling hard right now
i'm just trying to pull this thing
through this one needs a blow job this
is the time to do this for two brick i
can do two brick for these two he's
really rolling he's rolled charisma four
times now this is a new record for
hauntz
determination with the girl you would
have been [ __ ] just like asking him
where was this energy
she uh she's fine did you take the bra
off or you left the bra on she had no
bra to begin with
20 22 so 20 22 victoria's gonna feel
something out dude because women are one
of those downtown austin brothers
walking around in attendance with her
nipple showing yeah what do you want
breast cancer are people able to see
your nipples through your shirt
yeah
get it right home take off their shirt
get on only
pretty sure this putting this massage
gun on my neck gave me an aneurysm
passed out it's like this is too much at
this level
oh all right all right
it's a beard thing
do you know what i'm saying
give me your thigh
a three
it's too strong man
i want shots
shots please thank you
it's gonna be all right
uh
does anyone have any wheat if they will
trade me no
no i would have turned it to honda i
would have had it because i love this
one
thanks man
um
that bottle has a smiley face on it you
want this is it chris the one who pissed
that
yeah
this one's chris you bet dude
that's what winners do kiss on their
opponents
where you [ __ ]
[Music]
i just want to be part of it you know
sneaky bastard he's just trying to win
the game
brown guy have my kids sorry who's the
brown guy i think it might be me
[Laughter]
i think it's me like
in the game and real life
i'm the brownest
no
blackness with sexual prowess does
anyone want to trade us a lack of
neurodiversity
i don't
yes there's many different types of will
someone trade me a wood for a sheep
like a character i'm a typical black man
to have sex so you need a sheep yeah
i don't have one damn [ __ ]
uh rock for wheat anyone um
it's not even my turn i don't know what
i'm doing here [ __ ]
yo
thank you for telling me to come to
austin
who told you
every night oh thank you i would kill it
at a mic back home and then i'll get a
text at one in the morning for momford
you need to come out here
you need to be out here
you do good here
and then i came out here and i did good
here yeah
very grateful for this guy he's a good
dude man that's right virginia loki is
like a little hot spot
trying to keep up with you so wait all
right so how does the road work
does anyone have a sheep yes
what would you like i have wood
we all have wood
doesn't it look like a little uh talk
this spin on abe lincoln's
he likes it looks like a hat like a
magician it looks like a thing you put a
pocket uh i rolled the tag
the little shallow ass tanga egg yeah
or uh the i have the smallest fleshlight
they make it's like
four inches of insertable length it's
like on the thing does that mean you
have a small dick if you have a small
fleshlight honestly i poke out two
inches on the other side oh
it's two zero
yeah it's not like spencer's i'm not
[ __ ] anything from spencer's gifts
okay only about this gift was like a
godsend to every seventh grader
you don't have to be 18 to buy a
flashlight that's a hat [ __ ] i didn't
even know that what
yeah dude anything you buy spencer's
automatically has an std on it though
it's been like michael's wife
why
okay like how do you know i was married
to a chucky doll
she's not a chunky dog
no i'm sure your wife is clean
she is she's the reason why i shower and
brush my teeth
make a difference
it transfers hygiene habits okay you
can't eat acid
you can't get [ __ ] with stinky breath
dog i mean you should but it's like not
like quality it's not good [ __ ] five
five five
five dollars i'm done yeah five five
goes west
how many nights have you ever goes west
meet schindler's list
and have you played any nights
yeah
i love that guy well it's very sweet
he's very sweet his offstage persona was
polarizing compared to his onstage
so how long are you in town for
wow that's good
yeah he's very sweet yeah you were
really funny you did really yeah you did
really well
funny i liked it good stuff sweet guy
wait who is this william montgomery
yeah
on stage he's like yelling and screaming
off stage oh
we're glad to have you
it's like the dad from every sitcom in
the age yeah he's one of the good whites
yeah
he's one of the good ones he looks like
he could be your brother okay well yeah
what if i said that about it
hey you said one of the good ones
you guys have the same dad are you done
what drinking what's your turn
yeah
um
[Laughter]
uh you've done [ __ ] me because of you
i'm sorry that this love [ __ ] you over
somebody in the chat talking [ __ ] about
you and the whole chat turned on them
what'd they say about me said hans would
be more interesting if he wasn't as full
of himself
wow
that's pretty hard and then really kevin
followed by change kevin change your
name to karen
do you have a name for your fan base
yeah kim sells kim
that's good dude
kim
hell yeah thanks man
someone in the chat came up with that
kim cells okay that's good you credited
the chat that's chris wins
i will say that one person
said whatever it is
i i played a good game this time i think
it won it's the best game i've played i
did how thank you guys for not giving
him the big one
i got the largest army kevin bergman
what does that mean
i played knights
oh
i forgot that this was even a car until
like two turns ago where'd you get that
from it's like on the side it was over
there
how do you how did you get that um
it's just like an achievement like so
you have the most nights yeah and he has
a victory point yeah
sneaky [ __ ]
well hans you're only all pushed on the
toilet man that's not a good stretch
rule to make
should have pissed off the toilet if you
shut your piss
this [ __ ] said you can already tell hans
is thinking about everyone leaving his
space
[Laughter]
i don't feel welcome anymore i'm not
getting red i'm getting hot dude isn't
it
better that that [ __ ] is so funny
but i'm letting you stay here yeah if i
wanted you guys what a generous guy i
love that last night hila jacobs he goes
no no i don't you guys don't have to
leave i just thought you would have been
gone by now yeah
that's the
hands down the funniest like
that's the funniest thing i've ever
heard someone say to like no you should
get the [ __ ] out of my house hans down
funniest
i don't know why you guys stayed so late
last night because you how late is late
for work like this
it was later than that it was like about
the same time we did not get back to
mumfords it was it was for something
[Music]
and then we gotta go back to bucky's and
then tomorrow we got to go to terry
black's i want to go to terry blacks
before we leave jacket under an aids
quilt in front of arch
in the box
do it what
uh and it's going to be your callback
but terry black's is great it's just
gonna cost like 50 bucks whatever oh
that's so bad it'll be alright
that's way better
i want to go to terry black's paraglax
is good it's quick too it's like a
buffet
it's a buffet they get you in and out so
i'm saying i don't care about the price
like i don't care how much it costs it's
not a buffet but it's like a buffet
style like you just go up there it's
like super sour oh now they weigh in
yeah yeah oh okay yeah they waste the
meat but you uh you order the sides and
then you order
[Music]
and are you usually more energetic in
virginia beach is it just because you're
in a new environment you're not ready
it's because it's talkative three a.m
so you never stay up until three a.m no
[Laughter]
it's because you have a day job now yeah
i do yeah fine i'm brad says
congratulations chris real world yeah
right thanks man someone needed red oh
coming from brad i thought
brad said
congratulations chris hans don't invite
him next time
casa del kim dude it's kind of annoying
to me
i just ended up doing my beds
i did so like i didn't
[Laughter]
yeah someone said go there but we were
just talking about when do they open or
close
if you type in white castle on google
maps in the austin area you boy burgers
comes up yeah cause i was like i wonder
if they have a white spot off yeah but
it's better than like it's the trade-off
[Music]
when do they open bread or clothes brad
i thought jew boy is more of an iowa
kind of guy
do they sell kosher there you're big
you're heavy on the iowa
yeah
that's my uh
delicious what
video tacos well you know what i saw
i'm like a sexy little one
who
is my sister girl you said a sexy little
wattard very tired
disappeared into the green screen guys i
know you guys are from the mainland so
he doesn't know how to use the toilet
yet
yeah they got toilets we just squat a
little bit sometimes i got a squatty
potty dude
you have no excuses that's true what was
with that little like step that you had
it's a squatty potty body what do you
mean by squatting put your feet on that
thing and [ __ ] business
stop getting all your news from weibo
yeah dude open up reddit once or twice
damn i have everything i need for act
like you should see any ads on there
you don't have any white women in your
life to tell you what a squatty potty is
you don't need that
i had a girl piss on my car on friday
night on that car yeah she was leaning
on like so then you took it out on
hanz's toilet as your
reparations basically i treated it like
a trade-off yeah like a michelin tire
basically
girls have a harder time holding it in
the men because they don't have the
little
you know nozzle the valve the valve yeah
because it comes out
like gosh
i thought you're going to say something
really feminist and funny i was getting
ready to laugh
but then you interrupted it and then
we're anti-feminists
oh
what are you doing calm down buddy
calm down relax aunt yeah i did say
something antoine
they have an open wound but you were too
busy going
oh i didn't hear that too bad that's not
that's not the anti-feminist it's pretty
anti-feminist yeah i hate feminists
they're destroying the dating culture
yeah we should beat them up
said that a little
too casually
you answered your question
that's the confidence of a man with a
decline in population
this man has two children yeah
how do i explain the gray hairs
yeah he's only 17 years old
[Laughter]
he had twins at 15.
no damn dude you're on jerry springer
yeah sorry yeah i saw something that
christian went through a lot after
momford's asked me
yeah and that chair sunk down real deep
into you yeah
i'm happy for it yeah buddy some things
women that
it's where the caleb is looming over us
um caleb i feel like i feel like you're
welcome and you know i love you
hey i actually i wanted to ask if
anybody has an edible connect yeah what
do you need you just use this with drugs
yeah yeah
why don't you just sit down
yeah yeah
i would say i don't have any
on me currently but i have plenty back
home
okay do you want to sit down though
you should tell them how many milligrams
are in the ones back home bro yeah i got
you caleb
i don't have them now
oh man you know what that
that was such a isn't that funny that we
look at the public as just a source to
get drugs from
yeah
public
yeah the regular public or people that
you meet throughout
caleb sitting upstairs and then there's
all these people downstairs you're just
like people oh yeah that's the sad part
i'm seeing a lot of work to help you
there you guys should check it out why
what are you doing up there yeah what's
going on guys
and not doing bikes
last year yeah you saw me at um
i saw you at [ __ ] santa cruz santa
cruz theater yeah which was that
you guys didn't even know that did you
not do much
oh i do mics here and there
i just but then this guy
hit on a 12 year old oh yeah that's not
yeah
fair mistake
the good ones always get caught up
michael you okay
huh
are you mad at me no all right
is the stream done hans or did the
lights what's y'alls just died okay sick
huh yeah what's your what's
nick d's comedy
like mickey's nuts you spelled my name
oh okay mom for damn what's your yeah
what's your favorite it's uh
i don't think his name is david
tell them your handle yeah
mine here's the funniest one yeah
programming information
all right it's the least progressive
hangout for an asian guy [ __ ] you no you
ain't from virginia yeah that sounds a
little bit
it's the most progressive all right i
sounded i sounded very stupid when i
said that are you going to follow me
chris go back chris
are we friends
yeah
after that do you have any animals
no he ate them
all
what is this guy doing for us what is he
doing man she comes out
it's all the social progress man i have
like negative three white girls coming
to me now because it's like
embrace it why girls won't like
i want a half asian half white girl yeah
that's all i want man that's all i want
dude yeah you wanted my first my first
girl well i want one my first girlfriend
was filipino and white i was too
aggressive that's how much i love them
i wasn't sure if you were saying like
like muddy up the bloodline or like what
you're you're like oh there's just i
want to have a half asian half white
girl and i was like they're hot they're
hot my first girlfriend was like that
yeah do you like that it's a physical
representation of your inner psyche
yeah i just date myself
but a better representable
representation of my mental
representation are you doing good yeah
it's like a [ __ ] avatar or like uh
yeah why don't you have access i got
hacked all right
the russians
nigerians actually yeah [ __ ] those
blacks
i wish you guys would have all laughed
at that yeah i know if only you uh
pissed everyone off before you said it
edible connect texas is archaic
is it legal in virginia yes yeah
it just was about six months ago it's
six months
better than us because you're six months
ahead [ __ ] running that [ __ ] actually
like if you think about it virginia
should have been one of the last i was
surprised we had a very democratic uh
governor
did emotions are good you mean well
no he was
he was
democrats are for weed yeah and
blackface
yeah yeah maybe democrats
any [ __ ] that means he was like he
was getting the babies he was getting
the babies from the hospitals he was
taking the abortion babies
right
no one knows what i'm talking about i
know what you
yeah i don't know what you're talking
about it makes no sense to be like we
had a democratic governor yeah that's
that's how you get legal weed with
democratic governor
it's not wrong
i don't know what the [ __ ] you guys are
trying to say
but uh yeah i mean uh texas is backwards
we're just like [ __ ] stubborn and
we're like we started out on this
anti-wheat path and we're not going to
give it up no matter what the evidence
is
it's not like we have a history of
listening to evidence this is the uh oil
kind of easy enough to get it though the
oil companies don't want to lose
just be happy with it everything's fine
does it even matter that it's illegal
because i mean it's so easy you can
smoke it wherever it doesn't even
who cares what the law says
somebody said i'd better trade your dick
pics later
the law is important symbolic and it's
it's also real world impact like i have
we have a friend a mutual friend that
got arrested who in between houston and
austin [ __ ]
chris castles no and now they have to go
back to
takes a little bit of effort to uh
i love you too
i'm gonna go piss on the seat again it's
important to legalize [ __ ] that should
be legalized and not let cops do
whatever the [ __ ] they want to the
populace amen yeah mushroom should be
into that
yeah cocaine as well
yeah mushrooms
actually all drugs should be legalized
it's the free market yeah
because they're they're all beneficial
in some manner even if you know just
don't take that too much
loss for crimes
if you get high
and you beat the [ __ ] out of someone
there's a law firm oh he can look pretty
oh we can we have we have a correction
to your point there was a democratic uh
senator and governor uh hickenlooper who
was very much against
the [ __ ] up bumper uh this is a
functioning functional
i said that
it's not even trying
me
me
me and have you ever been in a situation
before what situation do you need food
are you all right no i'm not okay with
situations calm down okay it's gonna be
all right all right are you mad at me no
do you think we're the enemy
we're your friends yeah you guys are
cool yeah
also
i will say the comments say
that's why the chick that's why the
chick left he started talking politics
but they said it when he went to go to
the bathroom
oh there's a chick here
i'm sorry
sorry chris
dude chris slaps close
he crashed that's why he's walking
around his house with no socks
i
i feel comfortable here but i wouldn't
take my socks off
i didn't have socks
i just had shoes really she's no socks
dude in this weather yeah it's laundry
day today there's no excuse you're grown
up you'll start to act like it
i can accept the dirt
that's washed
i'll just kidding
no oh you got that she'll give my
brother my underwear
do you still live with your mom yeah
i love family right now i'm a deadbeat
really yeah so you're just your friend
your family lives in texas huh your
family lives here i'm born and raised
here yeah do you do anything for your
family or do you just mooch out for them
i cook i clean i vacuum walk the dog
i do almost nothing
you do anything a 12 year old could do
damn
take it easy on chris he's trying to
build i know yeah we should just be nice
to each other for four hours yeah
no that wouldn't be too fun can we just
have
yeah exactly
we shouldn't live in a nerfed world we
should be honest with each other yeah
and not be worried about speaking of
which i mean um
i want to go home then
you don't want to hang out with us
anymore because we're white are you mad
at me
are you mad at anthony because he fell
asleep during a conversation dude you're
asking yourself you're not working
i think you should be directing those
thoughts directly at hans i'm not hans
do you not want to hang out with me
anymore
no i want to hang out with you guys i
just wish that we uh
kind of figured out how to like not
interrupt each other a little bit more
you was getting frustrated i was
watching i'm trying my best
i think it's valiant the effort that
you're putting in
thank you see i know one of the girls in
the comedy team that you've had sexual
relations with um i won't say it but i
just wanted you to know that i
know you know
oh my god
what does that have to do with me
hooking up with the guys chief yellow
skin you hit that with the girl
it's like you're out here
yeah it's okay yeah
i support it i just
i just wanted to mention oh so long
i gotta go take a [ __ ] on the toilet
seat
make sure you put the seat up is that
blackmail mudford no it's brown male 1
nah you shouldn't be ashamed
on that yeah i am
why about what
did you no
oh no i had sex with the comedian no he
has
i know who you had please don't i know
so you have had sex with the comedian
yeah guys i didn't
i didn't
think
they always you always hear you're not
supposed to do that and you never know
until you do it until you make that
mistake so you did it was it a mistake
no it was a good sweet sweet i think i
learned a lesson okay i think yeah okay
what's the lesson eat [ __ ] from behind
yeah
no don't you shouldn't do that it's not
good it shouldn't
be [ __ ]
if you don't get too clingy i think it's
good yeah i don't see why you can't eat
[ __ ] from behind that's not what he's
saying
he's saying he shouldn't [ __ ] comedians
ever everything that's like a blanket
statement that's not always true
from comic to comic though
i don't know just in general you
shouldn't just judge them based on their
occupation you should judge them on a
lot of different criteria it depends on
the person really exactly
you should judge them not based on the
comedy that they do but like whether
they're compatible with you
yeah that's part of the compatibility
i just think that it's stupid to be like
you can't date any comedians because
that's who we spend the most yeah but
but for the most part it's gonna it's
for the it's for your own benefit if you
just if that's your rule and you live by
it then i think it's the way it is the
annoying thing is that guys don't wait
girls okay go ahead
guys don't give a [ __ ] about that the
girls are like i've heard that we
shouldn't [ __ ] the guys because they're
comedians well they're easily influenced
by society
i don't know i don't really know how
much i like believe i had like six
females or agree with that rule because
this is the first time
that i've been single since i started
doing stand-up so like i don't see like
i don't
know i see it as an occupational hazard
because i agree
comics are around comics more than
you know just don't date the crazy ones
there's some here where they'll like try
to ruin your careers there's other cool
ones who just
that's like that with any yeah it's all
about compatibility i mean genevieve and
marcus owens seemed good yeah tom segura
and chris
and they're success yeah like are uh no
no mosha casher and natasha legero yeah
yeah there's a large there's a lot of
them do you respect the glass
no
at this point view if my arms are long
enough
jesus christ i feel real i feel like i'm
on
i'm on uh
reservation land right now i'm not
supposed to be here
no i think that it's fine to [ __ ] comics
it's just you got to do it correctly and
not like do it disrespectfully and if
you like
i think them like [ __ ] then i didn't do
that and i didn't mean to be
disrespectful no i'm not saying you are
i'm just saying that's the pitfalls that
you gotta look out for
if you went into it amicably and it
ended amicably i don't see that as being
like an occupational hazard just don't
be toxic or petty that's that's
don't be an [ __ ] if you [ __ ] if
you could [ __ ] another comic and then
when it's over and done with
just walk away and not be like worried
about that person [ __ ]
salting your business up
then you're good
yeah it's just more [ __ ] on the line
where you have to be better
but uh that should be the least of your
concerns
should like be trying to be a good
person regardless of your career impact
somebody had a good point about how like
the girl that you date her skill level
is associated with you would you date a
girl i'd know that comedy i said that
yes that's a good point like we were
talking about this earlier this pretty
established comic has dated someone and
then she started doing comedy and it's
like working out all right
yeah yeah
yeah like would you date somebody like a
female comic is more successful than you
like like nikki say if nikki glazer was
like why would he not he has nothing
to lose he has everything to gain she's
hot and she can help him out
yeah but that's so here's the thing
do you go into that relationship
understanding that because that person's
further along than you it could work to
your benefit of course that's always it
looks like a hip you know what it means
it's like a weird dynamic right like
it's a very weird like because as
someone who's
coming up
if you end up [ __ ] hooking up with
somebody that's way ahead of you and is
getting bigger gigs or getting bigger
opportunities and is making more money
than you
then it's like
like your man is supposed to make more
money it's supposed to be more
successful
i don't know so much about that but i'm
saying like from a standpoint of like
you have to know the roles like you have
to know going into it like and the rules
are usually the opposite sure get used
to a different way of doing things i
mean look at um
but if you're smart enough you can
[ __ ] rationalize that joe list and
his wife [ __ ] will take turns
working with him for each other him and
sarah
like either shell headline and he'll
feature or vice versa yeah they know
where they are and they're honest that
they don't have to lie yeah create like
a fantasy
just so their relationship can survive
and i think that's definitely possible i
feel like that's how it should be
yeah it shouldn't be like man's always
in charge the woman's always on bottom
it should be like whoever's in the top
is on top sometimes i like to be on
bottom
i think every guy likes to be on the
bottom
you just lay there like what
i'll let them
would you get [ __ ] with a strap-on
no don't break me dude i had one girl
try to eat my ass and then another girl
tried to finger it and i like almost
kicked her like a horse weren't you like
pro
i don't mind eating ass and all that i
don't know but don't you know that's the
email
is on the prosthetic
[Music]
don't you know that the male g-spot is
in the prostate people
though if you don't go through the ass
you're missing out on a whole level of
experience oh yeah damn brad brad said
he's not brad said he's not a joe list
man don't experience that like
there's some dudes like it's that
doesn't not everybody is a jokes fan who
gives a [ __ ] yeah the [ __ ] you want brad
i don't like you
yeah
sorry it doesn't matter what random
people say yeah but yeah i mean you
don't have to experience everything but
it's understandable
it's just a another thing on your body
are you gonna like constantly be ruled
by the culture that you're in and not
experience different parts of your body
because people say eating ass is amazing
did you enjoy it because that's what
2022 told you she did yeah um i don't
think i've ever had that actually
people rave about it i had one do it
right hans what do you do i really do
experience it
somebody said i'm pretty sure the other
dude clogged the toilet he's been gone a
while who's in there
they're talking about you and they
thought you've been gone for a while i'm
still here no they're talking about
[ __ ] sweat
that's badass i wish i could draw
that's a cute picture i love it
you don't want to stay up past your
bedtime you good little asian boy yeah
yeah i did a pretty good job i got to be
up in two hours
i did a pretty good job for you dude
yeah we're gonna take a nap kill tony
tomorrow chris i'll be there okay let's
get it
no y'all you're getting it man you're
out of town you already got it yeah i
got it
yeah
he killed it he put me after jared
nathan he killed me
on a secret show i've never i've worked
at vulcan since may i've never seen
anyone that went last on a secret show
crush harder than this guy right here
the audience the audience wasn't the
audience was dead for the previous five
comics really this [ __ ] went it
was a call to arms
he got them he [ __ ] like brought like
generated energy from himself there's
very few people
yeah yeah it's impressive it's good it's
the combination of asian intelligence
and that's the last person
let me [ __ ] finish
realizing people are in the middle of a
sentence
it's the combination of asian
intelligence and mexican work ethics
mexican energy
mexican energy mexican what is that what
is mexican energy man i'm sleeping
i'm sleeping what
mexican
[ __ ]
like minority sort of like [ __ ]
trashy little
uh you know in the moment presentness
and making it awesome
thank you
is that you giving me a compliment hans
yes are you telling me good job in the
moment
[Laughter]
well i haven't seen it put put the clip
online dude i have the full thing you
want to watch it right now yeah no i
wanted to watch it
okay well i'll post it on youtube and
i'll send you the link
yeah okay i'd love to watch it and he'll
message me two weeks later it was pretty
good
did okay i was exhausted he had a couple
of things to be in that environment hans
would be like he lost him a few times
but she brought him back why are you
making himself chinese like he's from i
don't know
dynasty
yes he has like the i'm sure you know
you know you you uh criticize yourself
and like
yeah i do
yeah i feel like every like could always
be better but but i mean overall you did
great i mean you went last and you
[ __ ]
killed this what'd you do super high
energy high charisma move around talk at
the crowd
um
somebody's got an appointment
you can't do
um a little bit just have a lot of
material and then yeah high energy there
was an asian male and a white female
couple in the crowd it was god's will
i was like
i talked to him a little bit i wasn't
going to give her that soda can dick boy
i said a bunch of [ __ ] yeah
and
and then i did the i finally did the
asian alphas are
asian betas well no
asian alphas are just asian betas that
can [ __ ] white girls
i finally got to say that on stage and
that hit and then
you know and then i talked about my wife
and her
beautiful butthole perfect perfect yeah
it was good
i definitely put on any other job where
you're like i talked about my wife's
butthole
yeah 200 people yeah yeah
i talked about how my wife has a pink
butthole and i said you know you ever
[ __ ] a white girl she has like that
black butthole
or you watch porn
because it's overused yeah it's like i
said i call it a raccoon eye
i say does you ever [ __ ] a black are you
you ever [ __ ] a white girl who's got a
raku nine butthole like they just have
that black butthole for some reason
their whole body's white but they have
the [ __ ] super dark [ __ ] skin
my wife has a pink starburst butthole
huh
yeah gumball
yeah it was good
keep talking about your wife i want to
see a picture now i've heard i've
learned so much about your life why you
are she's cute did i show you you
already know
you did something
[Laughter]
can i can i get a video of being like
michael your wife's hot so i can send it
she's cute
i could imagine spending the rest of my
life with her
[Laughter]
i [ __ ] uh i [ __ ] i move out here i
die in a tragic car accident and hans is
like oh my god i know how you feel about
it that's so rough
i'm so sorry do you want to sleep in my
bed
he's like you know what
i was like i know you're in a very
vulnerable state right now would you
like to come over to my house and make
out for six hours then i put you in the
inversion table
then i can eat your [ __ ] standing up i
knew you were used to dating an uh asian
comedian i think this would be a good
transition for you yeah
i have to fall
[Laughter]
i'm a glass half full
kind of asian
you know what i'm saying
um
not much it keeps coming in and out of
consciousness
you know it's a good joke when he wakes
up and laughs and then goes back to
sleep
he's been i feel like he's been having a
lot of bad dreams lately i had a dream i
won a game with katan
[Laughter]
he's like dude that's never [ __ ]
coming true bro you suck
canada's in asia
is that why we lost time
on your wrist
yeah yeah
i do have a knife horse on my wrist it
was twenty dollars i'm pretty good at it
i don't have many pictures with her no
is she real hans did you just go on
board on your instagram dude
oh yeah you're right
specifically i don't know scroll back
about six to seven one from december 18
2012. the one that's 57 likes i love
he's like i saw their wedding photos for
what it's worth hans i like that girl
from detroit
thanks man she was cool she's nice she's
cool yeah she's coming back
yeah hell yeah i should text her
mum for tech you're an alright person i
mean
my opinion doesn't it but
oh it does i like her yeah she's like
nice you know yeah she's nice she's a
little
dude she's married to you yeah i know
she's like weird and kinky
[Music]
yeah that's right
yeah this is chelsea she's funny
she has a big butt and a pit bull that's
mine now
i like that those two girls
i can't what do you think you'll name
your french bulldog
uh i think it's a french bulldog well
we'll get one eventually the goal is to
get a cat and a french bulldog
and a corvette c8 and a new supra
so american
yeah
i like cars i'm a car guy i work on cars
back home yeah i love that you went and
a new supra i just i would like to have
a community the new one is manual
redmond [ __ ] up he bought the he
bought the automatic one they're now
making videos
which is dumb because
the bmw that that super is based off of
already comes manual so i don't know why
they didn't drop it in a manual
yeah i like cars a lot
redman wants me to work on his car when
i move out here
and i was just like great investments no
they're not unless they're classics like
miatas
yeah yeah they used to be like two
thousand dollars now they're going up
like money it's just old boomers want
them i do yeah old old white guys
holy [ __ ] scared me too man i was like
am i in trouble right yeah
oh they're sleeping yeah there's like
three sleeping roommates upstairs i'm
sorry oh i thought it was just you
yeah yeah that was you guys i thought it
that's just youtube yeah
there's a bunch of things i'm sorry
that's at the beginning oh [ __ ] sorry
yeah you want to go yeah is it is there
any way you could connect me with
charmaine night night
night night in han's bed maybe
just leave them
i would like
can you bring aunt to kill tony tomorrow
just to see what just see what happens i
mean i will make it happen that's going
to make it weird just an introduction
would be nice
um
it's the thing you take off your wife
when you marry really didn't wake her up
by yelling at him i hope he did though
she smells like some laundry
yeah it's like a all the way what's a
garter a garter it's a thing that goes
like a thigh
sock
yeah and then you rip it off during the
wedding you like go under the dress yeah
like that
is this something that people see like
is this yeah it was very very cringy
it's a very cringy ceremony you have to
go under your wife's dress in front of
her parents who are already everywhere
it's kind of hot you want to know
something funny throw it so her parents
her parents are like bernie supporters
and [ __ ] they have the bernie stickers
all over their cars
but then when the pandemic hit we were
living with them and they were like you
can't do comedy
during the pandemic the [ __ ]
that's why he came in and they kicked
i know but they're liberals and they
kicked out the only asian person in
their household during covid which i
always thought was really funny
they're like hey i hope this isn't weird
around the holidays but you know why we
got rid of you right and then stop asian
hey so yeah that's why we put you in an
internment camp does it make you mad
that stop asian hate revolved around two
rednecks getting a really bad deal at a
rubbing tug
he wasn't related to us okay
i was like why is why did it take for
somebody to be like that hand job wasn't
good
and then yeah he looked like every other
school shooter though i know but like
why is it not like you being here
as a kid or are you getting beat up as a
kid you guys why was it gonna stop asian
haters yes talk about school shooters
but you always forget the best school
shooter that there ever was
good ol
oh yeah virginia
like being in virginia and being asian
at that time
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
see this is the representation we need
yeah yeah for sure you've been missing
out
you gotta go viral man yeah asians do it
better that's true he was like what's
the most efficient way
to take care of this
he's like i gotta look at my bullets
to kills ratio and be like this is how
you do it
this is where all these whites are
[ __ ] up you gotta go
and then they were like this is what
we're gonna do in deadpool and like give
him 12 shots only to take out an entire
group of people i just like to imagine
like every white shooter since the
virginia tech shooting it's like i got
to beat that agent
[Laughter]
function og says dude snoring is nice
[Applause]
his wife's his wife's bottle sounds
amazing
i [ __ ] love streaming don't talk
about his white spot like this
chill bro yeah that sounds future one i
[Laughter]
too oh it's so funny hans didn't the las
vegas shooter kill more people in the
hotel room where he shut him down on the
country yeah but it took a while to
break down that class
that glass was still like that glass is
like
also if you went to what was it who
who's the country singer that was
playing when they
bailed right away yeah and it wasn't
like everyone take cover it was oh [ __ ]
i'm out brother
oh
no y'all are on your own thing
sucks to be you nerds
i love the aunt posted i did not fall
asleep on his own story
somewhere around the time that he fell
the [ __ ] asleep
can't hang dudes wife's butthole sounds
amazing that's good that means you're
doing a good job of making it
sound excitable because guys like i like
starbursts here
probably at the end of the year hell
yeah dude and why wait that long that's
happening that's what i'm telling him
come on solidarity
is chelsea coming oh of course better
watch out don't bring it to kill tony
dude oh yeah so yeah keep at least
if i went on now you guys will have a
guaranteed table it might be every
episode
no and i know tony would be like tony
will bring chelsea up and ask her so why
do you [ __ ] this guy
and she can hang out with janice and
they could talk about the same thing why
do you [ __ ] red van yeah pretty much
oh man i'm looking for it because
chelsea that's like the inverse version
of your relationship she doesn't
understand like chelsea understands but
i don't think she'll understand until
she's out here and like okay he's wild
yeah she'll be like oh what the [ __ ]
it's crazy i was in austin for four days
and we actually absolutely wrecked it i
would i would pound um him but he's
asleep um
dude he pissed his pants
no he definitely did viewers oh bro girl
see [ __ ] if you lost control of your
bladder i might have to bully you
because you're not old enough
just because you got great hairs doesn't
mean you can pee your pants in public
i'm not going to pee on myself
chris peed on the toilet
yeah yeah i pee on you aunt do you want
to you want to see your crisp i've done
that too and i well it's okay
he's very cool like he was like i was
scrolling through your instagram
and i noticed you were a miata guy and
then he also he like sent me a local
miata austin texas group
uh joe white dude that guy is
surprisingly internet savvy for hillary
oh he is yeah i was gonna say the same
thing he also [ __ ] smokes a [ __ ] on
cigarettes he really does people tell
you smoke is going to kill him like i
don't know about that he's like 95 and
he's still crushing packs yeah and he he
said he was looking at your eyes
you play this but you don't play magic
together yeah it was looking at your
eyes you strike me as somebody that
would play manchester united
calling you a virgin
shut the [ __ ] up dude i was married once
i play magic together
i don't think it is it's definitely
the this is a little queer though now
that it's four bucks a gallon again it
hasn't been like this since i mean
there's a lot of mclarens out here yeah
i like i'm just saying you guys want to
share it
if like when you hop in it's a tub
the whole car is like a tub
and then you put the body panels all
around it it's really weird yeah i love
building a car
i've done it many times i kind of like
totally trying
what's wrong with the van does his knee
breaks
no it's fine does it need a
fleshlight wall mount what's up said it
needs to cost less to [ __ ] move that
[ __ ] around down how much how much
money does it cost to fill it you know
probably 130 dollars
i got this thing called joe rugging
money that i used
to buy everything i need
yeah so do you get a direct deposit from
joe
are you on payroll do you get something
every two weeks please give me the mma
podcast episodes i just got a cut of
that really no he just gives straight
pieces
that's cool
cash is king
[ __ ] yeah dude
yeah you don't really have to do much
with that i mean
yeah what's it like being part of the
inner circle
is it cool sometimes i'm like do i
really know joe rogan or did i just
dream it
[Laughter]
you said that right no i didn't say that
but i'm glad that you said that right in
the middle of what i was saying
he's not he's not only yelling at me now
he's the only guy chris i feel better
okay he's whispering
what is your hat
whistle pig whiskey shout out patrick
from uh whistlebig appreciate you
whistle pig whiskey an official sponsor
of the
hans kim katan live stream
you need to get some sponsors for this
preferably pit vipers so we can all wear
pit vipers i kind of want some good
vibers no [ __ ] best money if you're
going to spend that much money on
sunglasses
shut the [ __ ] up if you're going to
spend that much money
every time you snore
he's not he's cognitive at least he's
still like he could be having an
aneurysm and just died
because he's like on your side he's like
[ __ ] dude what am i supposed to do i'm
really scared i don't know han's like
i'm just you wanna lay in that bed i'm
dreaming about [ __ ] this black stuff
i'll sleep in the bed but i'll touch you
yeah just go in there it's not gonna be
in there
we should go to tywin's houses
we did go to ty's house last night and
they had a french bulldog over there i
love tywin
oh man you guys come to my house that's
so cool
he's not a south park man
he's like he's like
he's like the asian tommy wiseau
he looks like a canadian
he's like so uh oh cool so you guys i
did kill tony that's cool
[Laughter]
so you're flying from virginia
do they have a lot of uh comedy mic out
there
that's really cool
okay
coming up next to the stage hans kim ha
[Music]
he's cool though
i like his energy he's chill he was one
of the first yeah somebody told me who
said that like who said that like his
brother and his sister are all out here
but he's the only one who talks like
that
yeah i mean i don't know why ty talks
like that i mean it's bittersweet
we never talked like this once i mean he
was the crumpets my dear
he was like oh my happy for you he was
born in america i don't understand why
he's born in british talks i think he
talks like a [ __ ]
that one's for you on brad
all right french indochina time oh wow
so you forget your backpack at my house
wow i already [ __ ] it twice
i left you a present oh yeah yeah yeah
oh you left your backpack at my house
open the back pocket there's a little
gram of cocaine for you
don't do it all in one sniff
i use your backpack to kill american g.i
[Laughter]
here use this bag to carry the weight of
your sins
oh [ __ ] man we got a show going on in my
house
[Laughter]
everyone at work found out that i did a
show for one of joe rogan's friends and
now i'm [ __ ] like everyone that works
like okay my boss even told me you know
you have to fly out to austin at least
once a month now right and i go
well i was waiting for you to give me
permission to do that so yes i'll do
that
and then my wife said something along
the lines of
we can't work on our time we have to
work on god's time and i was like yeah
god's like that means you need to
[ __ ] do it right now suck tony's dick
right now yeah basically we don't need
to suck tony's dick on god's time and
god is telling him to suck tony
hitchcliff's dick yeah i mean i have red
man's approval i don't have tony's
approval
um at the secret show somebody said i
hate your shoes
during it was jessie the weed dealer
that has a spot across from
so never mind i just
sorry tony was on stage and he wasn't
doing like um he wasn't very happy he
wasn't very happy with the set or
whatever and tony was like i hate this i
hate this i learned nothing from this
yeah
yeah yeah i
[Music]
the shift that's like tony and then
somebody goes he's like i hate this i
hate this and then somebody across the
room goes i hate your shoes and he's
wearing his bright gold foil like a d
air max nice bro yeah
yeah he has like golden shoes on
his golden sheep with yeah
yeah and then um he said i hate your
shoes
and then i'm sitting up top on the
left-hand side leaning over watching
tony like wow tony you know wow
oh my god tony
and then somebody goes i hate your shoes
and tony [ __ ] goes like this he's
like telling a joke and he goes
right in like stone eyes like [ __ ]
medusa eyes me and i'm like
i didn't say it
no those shoes are great
i made those shoes that wasn't me
i love gold i love girls
you're a part of the crowd
well i didn't know where it is i walked
into cam's office
i wish i would have but i don't know i
would have said something dumb and like
give this fat autistic fillers you know
out of the green room did he knows you
no just look in your direction no i knew
it was totally unnatural and scary
that's what made me so nervous i was
leaning over the railway at vulcan
watching the show
i left tony so cool and then
[ __ ] i hate your shoes and then
like stonewall took the air out of my
chest i was terrified
i was scared i was like no you're the
next person i'm supposed to impress did
he say anything after that did he like
say anything when he looked at it no he
didn't say anything he just looked at me
like like when a parent is about to beat
the [ __ ] out of their kid at the grocery
store
that's how tony looked at me and i was
like i didn't say that i'd [ __ ]
didn't call me eight years i'm not gonna
[ __ ] interrupt the show let alone
this one maybe an open mic i'll probably
be like ha ha and an open mic when
you're bombing but i'm not gonna
yeah next time you meet him again he'll
admit nine new asians and then he'll
just be the next fresh face
now he just met this same comic nine
times he doesn't know that it's a
different person
his name's ty right
yeah that's me
wow tony you're really good